Hello, everyone, and welcome to your second drink of gossip. Well, as you know, this episode starts with the parkour cold open, and we got this letter from Ethan C in Littleton, Colorado. Ethan said, Jenna and Angela, first, I love y'all, both so much. Thanks, Ethan. The office is such a huge part of my life and everyone knows it. I have to share something that happened to me at work, and it's the only time the office has let me down. Now, I don't work in an office.
大家好，欢迎来到你们的第二杯八卦。如你们所知，这一集以跑酷的冷开场开始，我们收到了科罗拉多州利特尔顿的伊森·C寄来的一封信。伊森说，珍娜和安吉拉，首先，我非常爱你们俩。谢谢你，伊森。《办公室》是我生命中非常重要的一部分，每个人都知道。我必须分享一件我在工作中发生的事，这是《办公室》唯一一次让我失望。现在，我不在办公室工作。
I work in an amazing elementary school in Knoxville. Well, last Friday, we had our annual talent show. Now, let me preface by saying, we don't have normal talent shows. Ours are like no other. They're absolutely overflowing with highlights and our wonderful students. It's honestly amazing. Here's where it gets good.
我在诺克斯维尔的一所很棒的小学工作。上周五，我们举办了年度才艺表演。让我先说明一下，我们的才艺表演可不一般。我们的表演与众不同，绝对充满了亮点，还有我们出色的学生。这真的很棒。精彩的部分来了。
We had a group of kids do comedic parkour while we played the video of Michael Dwight and Andy parkoring behind them. I decided to join in on the fun because why not? Oh, no. Well, let's just say I parkured a little too hard and now I have a torn ACL. The office had me thinking I could parkour and I par can't. Anyways, I appreciate y'all so much and had to share this story. Maybe my letter can be used as a disclaimer on the second drink of gossip for those that need not parkour. Oh my gosh. Ethan, Sorry, but also that sounds like something I would have jumped in and been like, I'm going to do it with the kids. You know what I did?
我们有一群孩子表演了滑稽的跑酷，同时我们播放了迈克尔、德怀特和安迪在他们身后跑酷的视频。我决定加入其中，因为为什么不呢？哦，不。好吧，只能说我跑酷跑得太猛了，现在我的前十字韧带撕裂了。《办公室》让我以为我可以跑酷，但我其实不行。总之，我非常感谢你们，不得不分享这个故事。也许我的信可以作为第二杯八卦的免责声明，给那些不需要跑酷的人。天哪。伊森，抱歉，但这听起来像是我也会跳进去说，我要和孩子们一起做的事。你知道我做了什么吗？
What? You know, when Creed is talking about how he wants to do one perfect cartwheel? One perfect cartwheel. Yeah. That made me wonder if I could do a perfect cartwheel anymore. Did you do one recently? Not recently. This was like even 10 years ago in my 40s.
什么？你知道，当克里德谈到他想做一个完美的侧手翻时吗？一个完美的侧手翻。是的。这让我怀疑我是否还能做一个完美的侧手翻。你最近做过吗？不是最近。这甚至是在10年前，我40多岁的时候。
Mm-hmm. And I threw out my shoulder. Like I got a big crick in my neck. It was a debacle. It was a tragedy. I still in my mind, I can imagine my body moving through space, dancing, because I grew up dancing, or cartwheeling or doing a dive, all these things. And I cannot. I should not. I should not. I did a cartwheel, I think two summers ago in the front yard with the kids. How'd that go? I felt like I was in a car accident afterwards. That's how it felt. I was trying to teach my kids how to do a summer salt and it was the worst decision I ever made. I was like, this is for the people at the little kitty gym who are much younger than me. And I used to do cartwheels all over the place,
嗯哼。然后我拉伤了肩膀。就像我的脖子落枕了一样。那是一场惨败。那是一场悲剧。在我的脑海里，我仍然可以想象我的身体在空间中移动、跳舞，因为我从小跳舞，或者做侧手翻，或者做跳水，所有这些事情。但我不能。我不应该。我不应该。我想大概两年前的夏天，我在前院和孩子们一起做了一个侧手翻。结果怎么样？之后我感觉就像出了车祸一样。就是那种感觉。我当时正试图教我的孩子们怎么做前滚翻，那是我做过的最糟糕的决定。我当时想，这是给那些比我年轻得多的小健身房的孩子们准备的。我以前经常到处做侧手翻，
but I did. I sort of like, you know that minor fender bender where you're like, how, my neck is sore in my back? Yeah. And my arm. What's that about? I mean, it's not like I, I mean, I work out, I lift weights, I stretch. Why can't I do these things? Why can't I move my body like this anymore? Sam, can you do a cartwell? You're younger than us. Absolutely not. No. No, not in the slightest. I would blow both my shoulders out and my knees.
但我做了。就像那种轻微的追尾事故，你会说，哎呀，我的脖子和背好疼？是的。还有我的手臂。那是怎么回事？我的意思是，我不像我，我是说，我锻炼，我举重，我拉伸。为什么我不能做这些事情了？为什么我不能再这样活动我的身体了？萨姆，你会做侧手翻吗？你比我们年轻。绝对不会。不。不，一点也不会。我会把我的肩膀和膝盖都弄伤的。
Okay. You know what I did last night I was really proud of. I know, Ethan, we're getting off here on a tangent. Last night in the pool, in the shallow end, I did a perfect handstand and walked across the pool. See, now water, in water, I think I can do a lot of cool shit. Can you do a handstand in the shallow end? I don't know. Well, report back.
好吧。你知道我昨晚做了什么让我真的很自豪吗？我知道，伊森，我们跑题了。昨晚在游泳池的浅水区，我做了一个完美的倒立，并走过了整个泳池。看，现在在水里，我觉得我可以做很多很酷的事情。你能在浅水区做倒立吗？我不知道。好吧，回来汇报。
Ethan, thank you so much. I hope you're healing and on the men. We also got a fan mail flurry. Jenna, you might remember that you did a breakdown of the things on Aaron's desk. Yes. Yeah. You thought you spotted a ski boot and a stuffed dog with a little sweater that both said J.R.O.B. The only thing you could find that match that was a wrestling camp, which didn't make any sense.
伊森，非常感谢你。希望你正在康复中。我们还收到了一阵粉丝邮件。珍娜，你可能记得你对艾琳桌子上的东西做过分析。是的。是的。你以为你发现了一只滑雪靴和一个穿着小毛衣的毛绒狗，上面都写着J.R.O.B。你能找到的唯一匹配的东西是一个摔跤训练营，这根本说不通。
But a big thank you to Rebecca D. Greg H. Stephanie F. and Dave M. who all wrote in to say that the ski boot and sweater actually say, JFBB, which stands for Jack Frost, Big Boulder, a local Scranton ski resort. Well, that makes a lot more sense. It does. Why it's on a ski boot. Yes. And I guess we've learned that Erin is a snow skiing enthusiast.
但非常感谢丽贝卡·D、格雷格·H、斯蒂芬妮·F和戴夫·M，他们都写信来说，那只滑雪靴和毛衣上其实写的是JFBB，代表杰克弗罗斯特大博尔德，这是斯克兰顿当地的一个滑雪胜地。好吧，那说得通多了。确实。为什么它会在滑雪靴上。是的。我想我们了解到艾琳是一位滑雪爱好者。
But also I could see her wrestling. I know. I was going to say, I could see Erin just sort of like randomly collecting things from a sport she doesn't play because she's Aaron. Yes. I don't know. Well, Jonathan A from Los Angeles wrote in to say, Hi there, hoping this gets in when y'all take a second drink of gossip.
但我也能看出她摔跤。我知道。我正想说，我能看出艾琳只是随便收集一些她不参与的运动的东西，因为她是艾琳。是的。我不知道。好吧，来自洛杉矶的乔纳森·A写信说，大家好，希望这封信能在你们喝第二杯八卦时被读到。
In the scene when Pam and Jim tell the whole team about the pregnancy and everyone is chiming in, Ryan says, don't vaccinate it. Ha ha, was that scripted or improv? Love the pod. Well, Jonathan, I love this scene. I love the scene where we're in the conference room. It's at the end of the episode and it becomes clear that Michael, has spread all these rumors about people to cover up Stanley's affair. And just when Michael is about
在帕姆和吉姆告诉整个团队怀孕的消息，每个人都在插话时，瑞安说，别给它打疫苗。哈哈，那是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的？喜欢这个播客。好吧，乔纳森，我喜欢这一幕。我喜欢我们在会议室的那一幕。那是这一集的结尾，很明显迈克尔散布了关于人们的所有这些谣言来掩盖斯坦利的婚外情。就在迈克尔即将
to announce to everyone what the one true thing is, Jim chimes in and he says, it's us. Pam is pregnant. And everyone has a little sidebar comment. Actually, I think we should listen to it. Okay. You told everyone I was having an affair. Okay. Okay. Here's a thing. There was one true rumor out there today. I didn't want everybody to know what it was. So all of you are off the hook except for this one person. Well, then what's the one true rumor? We have a right to know. Michael, am I gay?
向大家宣布唯一真实的事情是什么时，吉姆插话了，他说，是我们。帕姆怀孕了。每个人都有点侧面评论。其实，我觉得我们应该听听。好吧。你告诉大家我有婚外情。好吧。好吧。这是一件事。今天外面有一个真实的谣言。我不想让每个人都知道那是什么。所以你们所有人都没事了，除了这个人。好吧，那唯一的真实谣言是什么？我们有权知道。迈克尔，我是同性恋吗？
The one true rumor, and this is going to ruin this person's life, is that... But Pam's pregnant. I knew it. I knew it. Her breasts were a tiny bit bigger. At first, I thought, oh, she has a new brawl with padding, but then I thought, Pam doesn't need padding. It just didn't add up, Jim.
唯一的真实谣言，这会毁了这个人的生活，那就是……但是帕姆怀孕了。我就知道。我就知道。她的胸部稍微大了一点。起初，我想，哦，她有一个带衬垫的新胸罩，但后来我想，帕姆不需要衬垫。这根本说不通，吉姆。
Okay. Thank you. Congratulations. That's really great, you guys. Don't vaccinate it. Who's the father? Jim. How far along?
好吧。谢谢。恭喜。你们真的很棒。别给它打疫苗。谁是父亲？吉姆。怀孕多久了？
Four months? Who's the OBGYN? Stop, don't. All right. All right. You know, just like the nosiest group of people. I know.
四个月？谁是妇产科医生？停下，别。好吧。好吧。你知道，就像最爱管闲事的一群人。我知道。
To answer your question, Jonathan, Ryan's line was scripted. All of those sidebar comments were scripted. I love how you guys fire them off so quickly. The scene was so fun to shoot. One of my favorite parts is when John is Jim slowly comes over and puts his arm around Pam to sort of shield her from Kevin, who's like coming up over her shoulder from behind her to talk about her padded bras. It was very funny. Everyone's like at the top of their game in this quick little scene.
回答你的问题，乔纳森，瑞安的台词是剧本写的。所有那些侧面评论都是剧本写的。我喜欢你们这么快就说出来。这一幕拍起来太有趣了。我最喜欢的部分之一是约翰饰演的吉姆慢慢走过来，把手臂搭在帕姆身上，算是保护她免受凯文的影响，凯文从她身后肩膀上方凑过来，谈论她的带衬垫胸罩。这非常有趣。每个人在这个简短的场景中都发挥出了最高水平。
I could not look at Creed when he will start asking about who's your OPG one. I know. I know. It's so funny. All right, everybody, well, please enjoy your second drink of gossip. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
当克里德开始问谁是你的妇产科医生时，我没法看他。我知道。我知道。太搞笑了。好吧，大家，请享受你们的第二杯八卦。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, you guys. I hope you're having a great day. Today we're going to talk about gossip. it is the season premiere of season six.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嗨，大家好。希望你们今天过得愉快。今天我们要谈谈八卦。这是第六季的季首播。
Holy moly, we're at season six. Yeah. We're going down the other side of the mountain. We hit the peak at 100 episodes. Now we've got one hundred four. Downhill all the way. No, that's not how I meant that metaphor to be. I just meant we're halfway to our destination.
天哪，我们到第六季了。是的。我们正在下山。我们在100集时达到了顶峰。现在我们有104集了。一路下坡。不，我不是那个意思。我只是说我们离目的地还有一半路程。
We're halfway there. Oh, no. Oh, and now I heard it. We go, go, go. No. Okay. Oh, I'm liking this. Listen, this episode was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein, and here
我们走了一半了。哦，不。哦，现在我听到了。我们走，走，走。不。好吧。哦，我喜欢这个。听着，这一集是由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧并执导的，这里
is your summary. When Michael regretfully reveals that Stanley is having an affair, he sets out to cover his tracks by spreading a bunch of lies about basically everyone in the office. But what he doesn't realize is that one of his lies turns out to be true. Before we get started on the fast fact. Angela, we have some gossip. Or maybe it's not gossip. Maybe it's true. Maybe it's the one true thing. Okay, it's totally real. It's not gossip. Guys, our book cover for Office BFFs is out. It is out. It's official. Right now. You can see it. It's so cute. Can I say that? I can say it's cute, right? I mean, I hope we think
是你的摘要。当迈克尔懊悔地透露斯坦利有婚外情时，他开始通过散布关于办公室里几乎每个人的谎言来掩盖自己的踪迹。但他没有意识到的是，他的一个谎言竟然是真的。在我们开始快速事实之前。安吉拉，我们有一些八卦。或者也许那不是八卦。也许那是真的。也许那是唯一真实的事情。好吧，它是完全真实的。这不是八卦。伙计们，我们的《办公室闺蜜》书封出来了。它出来了。它是官方的。就在现在。你可以看到它。它太可爱了。我可以这么说吗？我可以说是可爱的，对吧？我的意思是，我希望我们认为
it's cute. We picked it. You guys, I think you know this about me by now. I love a photo booth. This is true. If I walk by a photo booth with you, you're going to. in it with me. And Jenna and I went into a photo booth at the mall one day. This was years ago. Years ago. Ten years ago, maybe. Was it more than that? Maybe more. I saved the photo strip from this mall photo booth. It's been on my bulletin board for a number of years. And it's the photo of our book cover. I'm realizing now that we chose a 15-year-old photo for our book cover, probably because we didn't want to pose for a photo. But actually, the point of it was. to show the depth of our friendship, the length of our friendship, because so much of the book
它是可爱的。我们选的。伙计们，我想你们现在了解我了。我喜欢照相亭。这是真的。如果我和你路过一个照相亭，你就会和我一起进去。有一天，我和珍娜在商场的照相亭里。那是几年前的事了。几年前。十年前，也许。那是更久以前吗？也许更久。我保存了那个商场照相亭的照片条。它在我的公告板上贴了好几年了。这就是我们书封的照片。我现在意识到我们为书封选择了一张15年前的照片，可能是因为我们不想摆姿势拍照。但实际上，它的重点是展示我们友谊的深度，我们友谊的长度，因为书的很大一部分
is going over the growth and history of our friendship. It is, you guys. It is our life through the office and beyond, Best Friendship Journal with the backdrop of this amazing show and just a lot of our stories that we can't get into as much in the podcast are in the book. Also in the book are 400 of our personal photos. Can I just take a minute? 400, that was so hard to narrow down because we had like 2000. And they were like, you guys, your book cannot have 2,000 pictures. They told us we had to narrow it down to like 200. Jen and I were like, we got it to 400.
是在回顾我们友谊的成长和历史。是的，伙计们。这是我们通过《办公室》及以后的生活，以这部精彩的剧集为背景的最好的友谊日记，我们不能在播客中深入讲述的很多故事都在书里。书中还有400张我们的个人照片。我可以花点时间吗？400张，这太难缩小范围了，因为我们有大约2000张。他们说，你们的书不能有2000张照片。他们告诉我们要把它缩小到200张左右。珍娜和我当时想，我们把它缩小到了400张。
Yeah. Can we call it even? So these are truly our personal photos taken on our personal cameras. Even back then when you had the old-timey cameras with film. Yes, and you had to go to the mall to the kiosk. Yep. Yeah. Those pictures all the way back to the pilot.
是的。我们可以算平手吗？所以这些确实是我们用个人相机拍摄的个人照片。即使在那个时候，当你还有带胶卷的老式相机时。是的，你必须去商场的售货亭。是的。是的。那些照片一直追溯到《办公室》的试播集。
of the office, the book is available for pre-order now. We would appreciate it if you pre-order it because it makes us look really good to our publishers. I wish you could see Jenna's face right now because she's doing that really cute face that your kids do when they really want something at Christmas. So yeah, pre-order would be amazing. Thank you in advance. I know, the Midwesterner and me gets very shy asking people to do things like that. But you can find a link to order the book on Office.
这本书现在可以预订了。如果我们预订，我们会很感激，因为它让我们在出版商面前看起来很好。我真希望你能看到珍娜现在的脸，因为她正在做那种孩子们在圣诞节真的很想要什么东西时做的非常可爱的表情。所以是的，预订会很棒。提前谢谢你们。我知道，中西部人的我要求人们做这样的事情会非常害羞。但你可以在OfficeLadies.com上找到订购这本书的链接。
Ladies.com. We will, of course, put it on all of our social media platforms as well. Yes. So check out the cover. Office BFFs. Check it out. We can't wait to share this book with you. We're super excited to take it out in the world and meet you all and sign copies and do the whole shebang. And I will wear a fake flower. You mark my words. I don't doubt it for a second. Should we get back to the episode? Let's do it. Fast fact number one, gossip, as I said, was our season 1, 2006 premiere episode, it aired on September 17th, 2009, and it was seen by 8.21 million viewers. Wow. That seems like a lot.
我们当然也会把它放在我们所有的社交媒体平台上。是的。所以看看封面。《办公室闺蜜》。看看它。我们迫不及待地想与你们分享这本书。我们超级兴奋能把它带到世界上，见到你们所有人，签名并做所有的事情。我会戴上一朵假花。记住我的话。我一点也不怀疑。我们应该回到这一集吗？让我们开始吧。快速事实第一，八卦，正如我所说，是我们2006年第一季的首播集，它于2009年9月17日播出，有821万观众观看。哇。这看起来很多。
It was a lot. However, our viewership was down 18% compared to the season 5 premiere of weight loss. Oh. So I guess we took a little dip here with our premiere episode, but the office was still the leading comedy on NBC. at the time, and we were sort of the anchor for the other shows. I found an old promo. Oh, I love an old promo. That was kicking off the whole, like, fall season,
确实很多。然而，与第五季首播的减肥相比，我们的收视率下降了18%。哦。所以我猜我们的首播集有点下滑，但《办公室》仍然是当时NBC的领先喜剧，我们算是其他节目的支柱。我发现了一个旧的宣传片。哦，我喜欢旧的宣传片。那是开启整个秋季档的，
and the office was very prominent in it. Will you guys play it? Here's why summer being over is a good thing. Because now we get new comedy on NBC Thursday. That's cool. We'll finally confirm the big baby news on the office. GP, I had a stick. I didn't.
《办公室》在其中非常突出。你们会播放吗？这就是为什么夏天结束是一件好事。因为现在我们在NBC周四有新的喜剧。那很酷。我们终于要在《办公室》确认大宝宝新闻了。GP，我有一根棍子。我没有。
but it was inconclusive. And we welcome back Parks and Rec, 30 Rock, and S&L in primetime. Plus the new comedy community, a perfect fit on Thursdays. You ready, Megan? See. And it always ends with Jay. All your favorite comedies are back on one great night. Thursday, September 17th on NBC.
但结果是不确定的。我们欢迎《公园与游憩》、《我为喜剧狂》和《周六夜现场》在黄金时段回归。加上新的喜剧《废柴联盟》，周四的完美搭配。你准备好了吗，梅根？看。它总是以杰伊结尾。所有你最喜欢的喜剧都在一个伟大的夜晚回归。9月17日星期四在NBC。
Oh, man, I miss those promo guys. Those guys, they crack me up every time. They're like, all your favorites in one place. Yeah. They kind of do a breathy thing. Well, when I saw this promo, it made me think of something. What? Well, they say summer is over, you know, we're back.
哦，天哪，我想念那些宣传片的人。那些人，他们每次都让我笑。他们就像，所有你最喜欢的都在一个地方。是的。他们有点做那种喘息的事情。好吧，当我看到这个宣传片时，它让我想起了一些事情。什么？好吧，他们说夏天结束了，你知道，我们回来了。
Yeah, yeah. Why did the documentary film crew stop filming us every summer? There's always a time jump. Lady, because they're a faky film crew. I mean, why not film us in the summer? We jump ahead in time. It's been several weeks since Pam and Jim got their pregnancy news. And now, you know, she's quite far along by the summer.
是的，是的。为什么纪录片摄制组每年夏天都停止拍摄我们？总是有时间跳跃。女士，因为他们是假的摄制组。我的意思是，为什么不在夏天拍摄我们？我们时间跳跃了。距离帕姆和吉姆得到怀孕消息已经过去几周了。现在，你知道，到夏天这一集时，她已经相当显怀了。
this episode. I just, I'm like, why? Why did they, why do they take a brain? All right, fast fact number two. Gossip was the first episode to feature Ellie Kemper as a full cast member. It was also the first episode of The Office to air since the release of The Hangover, starring our very own Ed Helms. This movie was a huge hit. Yeah, ha huge. If you don't know it, it's the story of these three guys who go to Vegas for a bachelor party, but they lose the groom. And they wake up from this night of intense partying. The groom is gone, and they have to retrace their steps and try to find him. And Ed was one of the stars. This movie made $469 million at the box office. What the heck? Bradley Cooper, Zach Gallifanakis, Ed Helms became superstars. Ken Zhang was in
这一集。我只是，我像，为什么？为什么他们，他们为什么要休息？好吧，快速事实第二。八卦是第一集以艾莉·坎伯为全职演员的剧集。这也是《宿醉》上映以来播出的第一集《办公室》，由我们自己的艾德·赫尔姆斯主演。这部电影非常成功。是的，非常成功。如果你不知道它，它是关于这三个家伙去拉斯维加斯参加单身派对，但他们弄丢了新郎的故事。他们从那晚激烈的派对中醒来。新郎不见了，他们必须重走他们的足迹并试图找到他。艾德是明星之一。这部电影在票房上赚了4.69亿美元。搞什么鬼？布莱德利·库珀、扎克·加利凡纳基斯、艾德·赫尔姆斯成为了超级巨星。肯·郑也在
this movie, Superstar. I went to the Hangover DVD release party in Las Vegas with Rachel Harris. You didn't. I did. Because Rachel Harris was in the movie. Yes, she played Ed's girlfriend, the sort of persnickety girlfriend. I witnessed her plus one. And lady, guess where this big party was in Vegas?
这部电影里，超级巨星。我和瑞秋·哈里斯一起去了拉斯维加斯的《宿醉》DVD发布派对。你没有。我去了。因为瑞秋·哈里斯在电影里。是的，她扮演艾德的女朋友，那种挑剔的女朋友。我见证了她的加一。而且女士，猜猜这个大型派对在拉斯维加斯的哪里？
I don't know. Caesar's Palace. Oh, of course, because the movie. Club Pure. I found some red carpet. photos. No, you did not. From this evening. And I cannot wait to show them to you. Who? Angela! Angela has on boots that go up to her knees. Black leather go-go boots. Oh, wow. Look at you. I was in Vegas. You got to like bring out your boots for Vegas.
我不知道。凯撒宫。哦，当然，因为电影。Pure俱乐部。我发现了一些红毯照片。不，你没有。从那天晚上。我迫不及待地想给你们看。谁？安吉拉！安吉拉穿着到膝盖的靴子。黑色皮革高跟靴。哦，哇。看看你。我在拉斯维加斯。你得为拉斯维加斯拿出你的靴子。
So yeah, I went to the Hangover DVD release party. Well, we want you guys to know that Ed was a horrible person after he became a Star. No, he wasn't. He was just even more Ed. He never changed. What a sweet guy. We were so happy for this big success. Yeah. He went on to make more hangover movies and more movies and develop TV series, but he's still the same old Ed. He is. Fast fact number three, I have titled, What Did You Do Over That Summer? Hmm. Because I was like, this was like a life-altering summer for Ed Helms. It was a life-altering summer. It was a life-altering summer. It was a life-altering, altering summer for Ellie Kemper because she was made a regular on this TV show, I realized I had a life altering summer as well. What'd you do? Two very big things happened to me over this summer. The first thing that happened was that my beloved Andy Cat, you know, the one that was in the People
所以是的，我去了《宿醉》DVD发布派对。好吧，我们想让你们知道艾德在成为明星后是一个可怕的人。不，他不是。他只是更像艾德。他从未改变。多可爱的人。我们为这个巨大的成功感到高兴。是的。他继续制作了更多的《宿醉》电影和更多的电影并开发了电视剧，但他仍然是那个老艾德。他是。快速事实第三，我标题为，那个夏天你做了什么？嗯。因为我当时想，这对艾德·赫尔姆斯来说是一个改变人生的夏天。这是一个改变人生的夏天。这是一个改变人生的夏天。这对艾莉·坎伯来说是一个改变人生的夏天，因为她成为了这个电视节目的常驻演员，我意识到我也度过了一个改变人生的夏天。你做了什么？那个夏天我发生了两件非常大的事情。第一件事是，我心爱的安迪猫，你知道，那个和我一起拍《人物》杂志照片的猫。那个你为它配音的，你会以安迪的身份说话。是的，我会。我们还没有分享过那个。哦，抱歉，我们没有。没关系。每个认识我一直追溯到大学的人都知道我为安迪配了一个小声音。我告诉你，桑尼也有一个。哦，是的。你所有的动物都有自己独特的口音。它们有。因为顺便说一句，我觉得安迪的名字是安迪，但他发音为ony。安迪，是的，那是他做出的选择。对。所以无论如何，可爱的安迪在那个夏天去世了。他快17岁了。但那对我来说是一件大事，因为他一直陪着我从密苏里州的柯克斯维尔一直到好莱坞，他是我的爱。我知道。真的。所以那个夏天，
Magazine shoot with me. The one that you had a voice for, you would talk as Andi. Yes, I would. We haven't shared about that. Oh, sorry, we haven't. That's okay. Everyone who knows me going going all the way back to college knows I had a little voice for Andi. I'll have you know Sunny has one as well. Oh, yeah. All of your animals have their own unique accents. They do. Because by the way, I think Andy's name was Andy, but he pronounced it ony. Andy, yeah, that was a choice he made. Right. So anyway, sweet Andy passed away over this summer. He was almost 17 years old. But that was a big thing for me because he had traveled with me all the way from Kirksville, Missouri all the way to Hollywood, and he was my love. I know. Really and truly. So also that summer,
虽然，安吉拉，李向我求婚了。哦，天哪，那是真的。是的。我们在巴黎。哦，巴黎，巴黎，巴黎。他在河边求婚了。我们正在吃带葡萄酒和奶酪的小野餐。搞什么鬼？这是浪漫喜剧吗？好吧，然后它变得更像浪漫喜剧了。因为李和我当时想，哦，也许我们把订婚的事保密一段时间。我的意思是，我们告诉了我们所有的亲密朋友，我们告诉了我们的家人，但我们想，也许我们暂时不公开这个消息。我不知道。是的，是的。只是保持私密。
though, Angela, Lee proposed to me. Oh my gosh, that's right. Yes. We were in Paris. Oh, Paris, Paris, Paris. And he proposed by the river. We were having a little picnic with wine and cheese. What the heck? Is this a rom-com? Well, then it got even more rom-com. Because Lee and I were like, oh, maybe we keep the engagement to ourselves for a little while. I mean, we told all of our close friends, we told our family, but we thought, like, maybe we don't go public with the news for a while. I don't know. Yeah, yeah. Just keeping things private.
好吧，这家巴黎小餐馆里的某个人无意中听到我们告诉另一对夫妇我们订婚了。所以当我们飞回家时，它上了新闻。我的意思是，谈论八卦。哦，天哪，这太符合主题了。你是八卦。所有的八卦杂志，我们着陆时收到了疯狂数量的电子邮件和短信。我们上了像《今晚娱乐》这样的节目。哦，天哪。
Well, someone in this little Parisian restaurant overheard us telling another couple that we had gotten engaged. So while we're flying back home, it hit the news. I mean, talk about gossip. Oh my gosh, this is so on theme. You were gossip. All the gossip magazines, we land to like this crazy amount of emails and texts. We were on like entertainment tonight. Oh, my gosh.
我的大家庭在给我打电话。这太疯狂了。但是，是的，那是一个伟大的夏天。好吧，我的故事没那么好。哦，不。我很抱歉如果我像。我当时想，我们要分享我们那个夏天做了什么。我想我没有给它背景。你没告诉我你要分享什么。好吧，奇怪的是，我也和肯·郑一起度过了那个夏天的一部分。哦，天哪。这是我们拍那部电影《毛茸茸的复仇》的时候。哦，是的。是的，我扮演他的，你知道，搭档。我们玩得很开心。你分享了关于他生日去P.F. Chang的疯狂冒险。是的，完全正确。但是，你知道，我们在波士顿外拍摄，我从来没有在那座城市花过很多时间，我只是爱上了它。两件事我
My extended family is calling me. It was so bonkers. But, yeah, it was a big summer. Well, my story isn't that great. Oh, no. I'm so sorry if I like. I was like, we're going to. to share what we did that summer. And I guess I didn't give it the context. You didn't tell me what you were going to share. Well, oddly enough, I also spent part of that summer with Ken Jong. Oh my gosh. This is when we did that movie, Furry Vengeance. Oh, yes. Yes, where I play his, you know, sidekick. We had so much fun. You shared about your crazy adventure for his birthday walking to P. F. Chang. Yeah, exactly. But, you know, we filmed outside of Boston, and I'd never spent a lot of time in that city, and I just fell in love with it. Two things that I
记得我喜欢的是，我带我女儿去了波士顿儿童博物馆。太有趣了。这个儿童博物馆里有很多很酷的互动东西。还有一个高桅横帆船节。高桅横帆船？是的。珍娜，它们就像古老的船，你知道，像探险家拥有的那种，像人们过来时用的。当他们像，世界是圆的还是平的？是的。是的。像五月花号，那些看起来像船的。对。还有古董。你知道我的意思吗？哇。但它们被称为高桅横帆船，因为它们有那些非常、非常、非常高的桅杆，对吧？
remember that I loved is that I took my daughter to the Boston Children's Museum. It was so fun. They have so many cool interactive things in this children's museum. And there was also a tall ship festival. Tall ship? Yes. Jenna, they were like ye oldy ships, you know, that like the explorers had that like people came over. When they're like, is the world round or flat? Yes. Yes. Like the Mayflower, those looking like ships. Right. And there were antiques. You know what I mean? Wow. But they call them the tall ships because they have those really, really, really tall mass, right?
为了帆。港口里大约有45艘。四十五。嗯哼。他们进行这种跨大西洋帆船赛。它从西班牙开始，继续到加拿大哈利法克斯，然后从波士顿出发，最后在爱尔兰结束。在古老的船上？是的。它们还在航行？是的。它们是复制品吗？它们是古老的船吗？好吧，我不知道，珍娜。好吧，我的意思是，我只是觉得它们可能是真正的古老船，因为，我的意思是，他们建造它们的方式，我读过书。是的。你喜欢那个吗？
For the sales. And there were like 45 of them in the harbor. Forty-five. Mm-hmm. And they do this transatlantic regatta. It begins in Spain, continues to Halifax Canada from Boston before finishing in Ireland. On the ye oldie ships? Yes.
我读过书。我读过书。也许它们是复制品，但我会告诉你，有16个国家参与，大约有1800名学员。哇。所以，是的，高桅横帆船，波士顿港。我让肯走来走去和我一起看它们。我某处有一张我和他站在其中一艘旁边的照片。这是我最喜欢我们工作的地方之一。
They still sail? Yes. Are they replicas? Are they oldie ships? Well, I don't know, Jenna. Well, I mean, I just think they could be real oldie ships because, I mean, the way they built those, I've read books. Yeah. Do you like that?
我能去，我能体验到我通常不会体验到的事情，你知道，在国家中部长大，我从来没有靠近过海洋。你知道，我直到我甚至不知道什么时候才看到海洋。我想我们有一年去墨西哥湾公路旅行。这只是，我不知道。有时我想到因为我们的工作我能看到和做的一切，我只是掐自己。哦，太酷了。高桅横帆船。高桅横帆船。我和肯在走来走去的高桅横帆船旁。你知道吗？我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，你和我应该尝试一些跑酷。哦，男孩。是的。好吧。
I have read books. I have read books. Maybe they're replicas, but I will tell you that it was 16 countries represented and about 1,800 cadets. Wow. So, yeah, tall ships, Boston Harbor. I made Ken walk around and look at them with me. I have a picture somewhere of me and him standing next to one. That's one of my favorite things about our job, or the place.
跑酷。我试着把脚放在桌子上，它伤了我的背，所以我没做。跑酷！你准备好了吗？你要跑酷吗？我要跑酷。等等，你要在播客里做视觉上的东西吗？我要做视觉上的东西。
I get to go and the things I get to experience that I wouldn't normally get to experience, you know, growing up in the middle of the country, I was never close to an ocean. You know, I didn't see the ocean until I don't even know when. I think we did like a road trip to the Gulf of Mexico one year. It was just like, I don't know. Sometimes I just pinch myself when I think about all the stuff I get to see and do because of our job. Oh, so cool. Tall ships. Tall ships. Me and Ken walking around tall ships. You know what? I think we should take a break. And when we come back, you and I should try some parkour. Oh, boy. Yes. Okay.
我要跑酷。让我们做吧。别真的做。做吧。天哪，别。你摇晃了整张桌子。珍娜，停下。跑酷！哦，我的天。哦，天哪。停下。停下。停下。伙计们，她从桌子上推开，摇晃了所有的麦克风。然后她跑到墙边。我想大约两英尺高，把脚放在墙上跳了起来。我喘不过气来了。我喘不过气来了。好吧，迈克尔、安迪和德怀特正在把他们的跑酷技巧在办公室提升到一个比珍娜刚才做的更具破坏性的水平。
Parkour. I tried to put my foot up on the desk and it hurt my back so I didn't do it. Parkour! Are you ready? Are you going to parkour? I'm going to park. Wait, are you going to do something visual in a podcast? I am going to do something visual.
他们只是从所有东西上跳下来。珍娜，你还记得那些家伙吗？他们真的毁了办公室。我记得。东西到处都是。是的。你知道，我们有一个来自意大利爱丽丝·R的粉丝问题。跑酷场景有多少是剧本写的和编排的？好吧，我联系了保罗·利伯斯坦，他编剧并执导了这一集。
I'm going to parkour. Let's do it. Don't really do it. Do it. God, don't. You shook the whole table. Jenna, stop. Parkour! Oh, my God. Oh, God. Stop. Stop. Stop. You guys, she pushed off from the table and shook all the microphones. Then she ran over to the wall. And I want to say about two feet high, put her foot on the wall and jumped. I'm out of breath. I'm out of breath. Well, Michael and Andy and Dwight are taking their parkour skills in the office to a much more destructive level than what Jenna just did.
因为在剧本里，它真的只是说他们在办公室里跑酷。他说他给史蒂夫、雷恩和艾德的指导只是一个基本的移动路线，以便摄像机能捕捉到一切。他说，显然，他们都没有任何跑酷技巧。他们根本没有进行任何跑酷训练。什么？我很震惊。它没有编排。他只是告诉他们，你不能做错任何事，
They're just jumping off everything. Jenna, do you remember the guys? They literally wrecked the office. I do remember. Stuff went everywhere. Yeah. You know, we had a fan question from Alice R in Italy. How much of the parkour scene was scripted and choreographed? Well, I reached out to Paul Lieberstein, who wrote and directed this episode.
你的目标只是尽可能多地弄乱房间。实现了。然而，他说第一次拍摄真的很令人失望。所以他们重置了办公室，他说在下一次拍摄时，他告诉他们所有人跑酷时大喊跑酷。所以每当他们尝试一个动作时，他们都应该大喊跑酷。所以他们会像从桌子后面做一个草率的翻滚，然后说，跑酷！是的。
Because in the script, it really just says they parkour through the office. And he said that the direction he gave Steve Rain and Ed was just a basic route to move through so that the camera could capture everything. He said, obviously, none of them had any parkour skills. They did no parkour training whatsoever. What? I'm shocked. It was not choreographed. He just told them, you can't do anything wrong,
他说这最终成了给它这种非常奇怪能量的东西。这非常有趣。所以是的，我觉得那很棒，实际上，因为我觉得很多喜剧来自他们非常自信的跑酷和他们糟糕的技巧之间的二分法。好吧，吉姆有一个很棒的谈话头，解释了正在发生的事情。他就像，你知道，这是2004年的互联网轰动。它在其中一部邦德电影里。
and your goal is to just mess up the room as much as possible. Achieved. Yet, he said the first take was really kind of underwhelming. So they reset the office, and he said on the next take, he told them all to shout parkour as they went. So whenever they attempted a move, they were supposed to shout parkour. So they would do like a sloppy somersault off the back of a desk and go, parkour! Yes.
女士，我觉得它在《皇家赌场》里。听我说。我爱丹尼尔·克雷格。是的，一样。他和一个叫塞巴斯蒂安·福康的演员有一场很棒的戏。好吧。我的意思是，它太酷了。谈论一场编排好的打斗场面。
And he said that ended up being the thing that gave it this really kind of weird energy. That was very funny. So yeah, I thought that was great, actually, because I thought a lot of the comedy came from the dichotomy between their very confident parkour. and their horrible skills. Well, Jim has a great talking head that sort of explains what's happening. And he's like, you know, this was this internet sensation of 2004. It was in one of the Bond films.
好吧，《黑客帝国》的很多东西不都是植根于跑酷吗？我疯了吗？什么部分？什么部分？他们在所有东西上跳跃。不？是因为在真正的跑酷中，你真的在做吗？你没有电缆之类的东西。是的，你不能在子弹飞过你时暂停时间。对。那不是跑酷。好吧，我和兰迪·科德雷谈过这个，他说吉姆播放的那个视频，那是来自加州大学洛杉矶分校的一名真正的业余电影制作学生在做跑酷的片段。哦，他们以300美元的价格获得了许可。然后我们有一位第六季的新平面艺术家叫瑞安·科斯格罗夫，他建立了一个假的YouTube风格的电脑背景。所以这就是你看到的。他把那个视频做成了一个假的视频播放器。
Lady, I think it was in Casino Royale. Hear me out. I love Daniel Craig. Yeah, same. And he had this great scene with actor named Sebastian Focon. Okay. And I mean, it was so cool. Talk about a choreographed fight scene.
不错。这就是在吉姆电脑上播放的内容。我觉得那种东西太酷了。我在这一集里记录了一堆道具。我觉得菲尔·谢很忙。仅在冷开场中，我们就有吉姆正在使用的苹果笔记本电脑。我们有迈克尔、德怀特和安迪正在使用的手持摄像机。梅雷迪斯的除臭喷雾。
Well, isn't so much of the Matrix kind of rooted in parkour? Am I crazy? What part? What part? They're leaping all over stuff. No? Is it because in true parkour, you're really doing it? You don't have cables and stuff. Yeah, and you can't suspend time as a bullet goes past you. Right. That's not parkour. Well, I talked to Randy Cordray about this, and he said that that video that Jim is playing, that was a clip of an actual amateur filmmaker student from UCLA doing parkour. Oh, they licensed it for $300. And then we had a new graphic artist for Season 6 named Ryan Cosgrove, and he built a faky YouTube-esque computer background. And so that's what you're seeing. He built that video into like a faky video player.
嗯哼。木梯、盒子、木托盘、垃圾箱、停车场里的垃圾桶。然后当我们进入这一集时，还有更多。好吧，你提到了那个手持摄像机。我们有一个来自英国利物浦克里斯·W的问题，他想知道那个摄像机是否真的在录制？是的，它在录制。当菲尔·谢买那个摄像机时，他首先咨询了我们的摄影师马特·索恩。他为这个摄像机得到了一个广播可接受的格式。
Nice. And that's what plays on Jim's computer. I think that kind of stuff is so cool. I clocked a bunch of props in this episode. I feel like Phil Shea was busy. In the cold open alone, we have the Apple laptop that Jim is using. We have the handheld camcorders that Michael Dwight and Andy are using. Meredith's deodorant spray.
它是每秒24帧的1080逐行扫描。所以他们在那个摄像机上录制的任何东西都适合广播。1080P。1080P。是的，我有时在电视上看到那个。是的。对，对。这就是那个。
Mm-hmm. A wooden ladder, boxes, wooden pallets, dumpster, trash bins in the parking lot. And then as we get into the episode, there's so many more. Well, you mentioned that handheld camera. We had a question from Chris W. in Liverpool, England, who wanted to know if that camera was actually recording? Yes, it was recording. When Phil Shea bought that camera, he first consulted with our cinematographer, Matt Sown. and he got a broadcast acceptable, I guess, format for this camera.
好吧。最终，我们只使用了。来自那个摄像机的两张图像。一张是在1分10秒，是艾德·赫尔姆斯在万斯制冷卡车顶上时的特写，然后一张是在1分14秒，显示了所谓的安迪跳下卡车时的背影。太好了。这些是我喜欢的小细节。我喜欢那个摄像机真的在录制它。他们使用了一些镜头。我知道。关于这个跑酷开场，我们还有更多的粉丝问题，安。来自北卡罗来纳州罗利的莉亚·B说，
It was 1080 progressive at 24 frames per second. So anything they recorded on that camera was suitable for broadcast. 1080P. 1080P. Yeah, I see that on my TV sometimes. Yeah. Right, right. That's what that is.
嗨，办公室女士，我是莉亚·B，我11岁。我已经看了三遍《办公室》系列，我只是想知道，艾德·赫尔姆斯在跳下送货卡车并落在冰箱盒子里那一幕时，是否有替身？盒子里有衬垫吗，他们为了拍这一幕拍了多少次？好吧，绝对有一个特技替身。
Okay. Ultimately, we only use. two images from that camera. One was at one minute, 10 seconds, which is a close up of Ed Helms when he's on top of the Vance Refrigeration Truck, and then one at one minute 14 seconds showing the back of quote unquote Andy as he jumps off the truck. So good. These are the little details I love. I love that that camera was actually recording it. They used some of the footage. I know. We had more fan questions on this parkour opening, Ang. Leah B from Raleigh, North Carolina said,
绝对有。我们整个跳下卡车序列的特技协调员，因为顺便说一句，那完全是100%计划和编排的。此外，那三个人在卡车顶上也是一种安全措施。有安全会议。哦，当然。我们的特技协调员是沃利·克劳德，他的儿子肖恩·克劳德是艾德的特技替身。
Hi, office ladies, I'm Leah B, and I'm 11. I've watched the office series three times, and I was just wondering, did Ed Helms get a stunt double for the shot where he jumps off the delivery truck and lands in the refrigerator box? Was there padding in the box, and how many shots did they do in order to get this scene? Well, there was most definitely a stunt devil.
埃里克·索尔基是迈克尔的特技替身，斯科特·莱瓦是德怀特的替身。但在他们上那个冰箱卡车之前，都是我们的人。即使是他们在停车场跑过汽车的那一幕。是的。那些是我们真正的人。事实上，我猜他们弄凹了那些车的一些引擎盖。它们必须被修理。
There definitely was. Our stunt coordinator for this whole sequence of jumping off the truck, because that, by the way, was completely 100% planned and choreographed. Also, just those three guys being on top of the truck was like a safety thing. There was like safety meeting. Oh, for sure. Our stunt coordinator was Wally Crowder, and his son, Sean Crowder, was Ed's stunt double.
但正是肖恩·克劳德跳下那辆卡车进入纸板箱。盒子里装满了泡沫橡胶。我猜他们有足够的物资做。三次拍摄，他们只做了两次拍摄，他们在剪辑中使用了第一次。他成功了。成功了。莉亚，我喜欢那个问题。我喜欢总是找出他们如何做所有特技的幕后故事。所以谢谢你寄来。所以听着，在进入这一集之前关于跑酷还有一件事，保罗提醒我，在我们拍摄这个冷开场之后，你记得吗？我们的摄像助理克里斯和艾德，以及其他一些工作人员。
Eric Solkey was Michael's stunt double, Scott Leva was Dwight's double. But until they were up on that refrigerator truck, it was all our guys. Even that scene when they're running across the cars in the parking lot. Yeah. Those were our real guys. And in fact, I guess they dented some of the hoods of those cars. They had to be repaired.
会不时在舞台上走来走去并大喊跑酷。就像他告诉我的时候，我当时想，哦，是的，我记得。就像是，跑酷。我记得我们都在做。是的。就像我们会打开冰箱然后说，跑酷！是的。好吧。
But it was Sean Crowder who jumps off that truck into the cardboard box. The box was full of foam rubber. I guess they had enough supplies to do. three takes, they only did two takes, and they used the first one in editing. He nailed it. Nailed it. Leah, I love that question. I love always finding out the behind the scenes of how they did all the stunts. So thanks for sending that in. So listen, one more thing about park horror before we get into this episode, Paul reminded me that after we shot this cold open, do you remember this? Our camera assistants, Chris and Ed, and some of the other crew guys.
这就是我所有的跑酷东西。我喜欢它。好吧，这一集以一点欺凌开始。是的，我们有实习生，暑期实习生。我们没有拍摄他们整个夏天，但这是他们的最后一天。是的。我们要抓住他们的最后一天。
would walk around the stage and shout parkour from time to time. Like when he told me that, I was like, oh, yes, I remember that. It would just be like, parkour. I remember we all were doing it. Yeah. Like we would open the fridge and go, parkour! Yeah. Okay.
德怀特向他们要了一杯水，然后他一饮而尽，然后说，好吧，看，凯文桌子后面的文件。我想要你们把它们全部按随机顺序排列，然后回来进行关于它们顺序的下一个任务。是的。我可以告诉你，这种欺凌在整个一集中都在继续，但它被删除了。哦。是的。
That's all my parkour stuff. I liked it. Well, this episode starts with a little bit of hazing. Yeah, we have interns, summer interns. We didn't film them all. summer, but here they are on their last day. Yeah. We're going to get them on their last day.
随着它的继续，你看到瑞安让他们为他做一堆复印件。嗯哼。其中一个实习生说，你知道你不应该和我们说话。然后切到德怀特说，是的，自从瑞安的事件以来，我一直在管理实习生。然后我们发现瑞安的事件是他让他们去银行拿了几百美元的便士，并让他们把它们全部铺在会议室的桌子上，让他们寻找稀有的旧硬币。所以德怀特负责他们。这感觉像是德怀特会让他们做的事情，实际上。我知道。
Dwight asked them for a cup of water, which he then chugs and then says, okay, see, the files behind Kevin's desk. I want you to put them all in random order and then come back for your next assignment concerning their order. Yeah. Can I just tell you that this hazing continued throughout the episode, but it was deleted. Oh. Yes.
瑞安说，这怎么比德怀特让他们做的更糟糕？这是德怀特让他们做的。他建立了一个办公室间消息系统，如果你有一条消息，他会把它写在纸条上，然后他会让实习生把它送过去，比如说，给安迪或菲利斯。所以这些实习生只是站在那里等待德怀特写一张纸条，然后他们必须把它送到任何部门。所以有很多实习生欺凌。它被删除了。它在DVD上。好吧，我可以给你一个实习生分析。哦，做吧。所以我们有莫里，由凯利·E·米亚塔扮演。安吉拉，他出生在我高中毕业的那一年。哦，好吧，就是那样。他现在30岁了。他是个年轻人。
As it continues, you see Ryan having them make a bunch of photocopies for him. Mm-hmm. One of the interns is like, you know you're not supposed to talk to us. And then it cuts to Dwight saying, yes, I've been managing the intern since Ryan's incident. And then we find out that Ryan's incident is he had him go to the bank and get a couple hundred dollars in pennies and made them spread them all out on the conference room table to have them search for rare old coins. So then Dwight gets put in charge of them. That feels like something Dwight would make them do, actually. I know.
是的。我发现这很令人谦卑。好吧，梅根由埃尔维·约斯特扮演。她现在只叫埃尔维。她出演了电视剧《外星居民》和《米尔德丽德·皮尔斯》。然后埃里克由马克斯·卡弗扮演。现在，马克斯后来在《绝望的主妇》中扮演了普雷斯顿·斯卡沃的常驻角色。哦，你喜欢《绝望的主妇》。
Ryan's like, how is that any worse than what Dwight made them do? And here's what Dwight had them do. He set up an inter-office messaging system where if you had a message, he would write it on a note and then he would make the intern walk it over, let's say, to Andy or to Phyllis. And so these interns were just standing by waiting for Dwight to write a note that then they would have to walk over to whatever department. So there was a lot of intern hazing. It's deleted. It's on the DVDs. Well, I can give you an intern breakdown. Oh, do it. So we have Mori, who is played by Kelly E. Miata. Angela, he was born the year I graduated from high school. Oh, well, there's that. He's now 30 years old. He's a young one.
哦，是的。他和他的双胞胎兄弟一起出演。他后来出演了《守望尘世》和系列剧《少狼》。当我看到他在《绝望的主妇》时，我当时想，那是实习生。我认识他。我当时太书呆子了，以至于我和《绝望的主妇》里的某个人有联系。所以我滑进了他的私信。你真的做了吗？
Yeah. I found that humbling. Well, Megan was played by Elvi Yost. She goes by just Elvie now. She has been in the TV series Resident Alien and Mildred Pierce. And then Eric was played by Max Carver. Now, Max would go on to play a recurring role on Desperate Housewives as Preston Scavo. Oh, you love Desperate Housewives.
是的。我觉得这让我很谦卑。嗯，梅根是由埃尔维·约斯特饰演的。她现在只叫埃尔维。她曾出演过电视剧《外星居民》和《欲海情魔》。然后埃里克是由马克斯·卡弗饰演的。后来，马克斯在《绝望主妇》中饰演了普雷斯顿·斯卡沃这个常驻角色。哦，你很喜欢《绝望主妇》。
Oh, yes. He was on with his twin brother. He has since been on the leftovers and the series Teen Wolf. When I saw him on Desperate Housewives, I was like, it's the intern. I know him. I like was so geeky that I had a connection to someone on Desperate Housewives. So I slid into his DMs. Did you really?
哦，是的。他和他的双胞胎兄弟一起出演了那部剧。此后他还出演了《守望尘世》和系列剧《少狼》。当我在《绝望主妇》里看到他时，我就想，那是那个实习生。我认识他。我当时真是个书呆子，竟然和《绝望主妇》里的某个人有联系。所以我私信了他。你真的这么做了吗？
I did. And he was nice enough to send in some audio clips about what it was like to be an intern on our show. And of course, we had to ask, how did he get his job on the office? Here's what he had to say. Hey, it's Max Carver here. I'm super happy to be on the show. I remember I went in for casting for the office. And I'd really, I'd never had any experience with comedy at the time.
是的。他很友好地发来了一些音频片段，讲述了在我们节目实习是什么样的体验。当然，我们不得不问，他是怎么得到办公室这份工作的？以下是他的回答。嘿，我是马克斯·卡弗。我非常高兴能参加这个节目。我记得我去参加《办公室》的试镜。当时我真的，真的没有任何喜剧表演经验。
I just, I just read it and thought, you know, I was going and be an intern. And the casting process was fun. I remember Allison was so sweet and we just had a laugh. I read it a couple times and then I was so excited. I couldn't believe I got the job. It was one of the first jobs I ever got in Hollywood. I was well aware of the show.
我只是，我只是读了剧本，心想，你知道，我要去当实习生了。试镜过程很有趣。我记得艾莉森非常贴心，我们相处得很愉快。我读了几遍，然后我太兴奋了。我简直不敢相信我得到了这份工作。这是我在好莱坞得到的第一份工作之一。我非常了解这部剧。
a huge fan of both the British version and the American version. So it was a dream come true. So Angela, when I hear his voice in that audio clip, that is exactly how I remember him on set. He was just kind and... They were really sweet. They were just young, nice, sweet folks. Well, I also asked him,
我是英版和美版的忠实粉丝。所以这简直是梦想成真。所以安吉拉，当我听到音频片段里他的声音时，那正是我记忆中他在片场的样子。他很友善，而且……他们真的很可爱。他们只是年轻、友善、可爱的人。嗯，我还问了他，
did he have any memories from his time on set? Here's what he said. One of the memories I have from being on set is that everyone there is just an improv master. So there's just not enough time on TV for all the amazing stuff that we saw. I think we probably shot an hour worth of content. And unfortunately, you only get to see 22 minutes. But at one point, I remember Dwight was lecturing us interns about an experience he had with a lobster,
他对他片场时光有什么记忆吗？他是这么说的。我从片场得到的记忆之一是，那里的每个人都是即兴表演大师。所以电视上根本没有足够的时间来播放我们看到的那些精彩内容。我想我们可能拍了一个小时的内容。但不幸的是，你只能看到22分钟。但在某个时刻，我记得德怀特在向我们实习生讲述他的一次龙虾经历，
which is a lobster for the record. and I just I could not keep a straight face I don't think that scene ever made it to air just because every time the camera panned over to me I was I was I just couldn't keep a straight face but Dwight is so funny
顺便说一下，是“龙虾”（lobster，他读成了lob-ster），我当时真的无法保持严肃。我不认为那场戏播出了，因为每次摄像机转向我时，我总是，我就是无法保持严肃，但德怀特太搞笑了。
Rain just knew exactly what would make me laugh so every take he just turned it up another notch and another notch and another notch I don't think you even cared if we got the scene you just wanted to make me laugh so I will never forget that. That scene is in the deleted scenes on the DVD.
雷恩很清楚什么能让我发笑，所以每次拍摄他都会更进一步，再进一步，再进一步。我不认为他甚至在乎我们是否拍好了那场戏，他只是想让我笑，所以我永远不会忘记这一点。那场戏在DVD的删减片段里。
And it's very funny. You know, Dwight is basically trying to impart his wisdom to the interns. And he has a huge speech. I'm going to paraphrase it. But he's like, I'm going to tell you a story about a young salesman who went out to a restaurant. And he ordered a lobster because he had never had lobster before. And he mispronounced it and called it a lobster. And he goes on and on to tell the store.
而且非常搞笑。你知道，德怀特基本上是在试图向实习生传授他的智慧。他有一大段演讲。我来转述一下。但他就像是，我要给你们讲一个年轻推销员去餐馆的故事。他点了一只龙虾，因为他以前从没吃过龙虾。他发音错了，把它叫成了“lob-ster”。然后他滔滔不绝地讲着这个故事。
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. That's amazing. Well, the last question I asked Max was, does he ever get recognized for being the intern, Eric, on the office? In terms of being recognized, yeah, you know, I think fans of the office are probably the most hardcore fans in the world. I've worked on a number of other shows. But the office is the one that keeps coming up. And it's always people like, I know you. I know you. You're from season six, episode one, which is just blows my mind. But it's fun to be a small part of that canon. And yeah, people remind me about the reams of sheets and Alan Thick. So thanks for that.
天哪。天哪。太棒了。嗯，我问马克斯的最后一个问题是，他是否因为在《办公室》里饰演实习生埃里克而被认出来？关于被认出来，是的，你知道，我认为《办公室》的粉丝可能是世界上最硬核的粉丝。我参与过其他很多节目的工作。但《办公室》是那个一直被提起的。总是有人说，我认识你。我认识你。你是第六季第一集的，这简直让我震惊。但能成为那个经典的一小部分很有趣。是的，人们会提醒我关于成令的纸和艾伦·锡克的事。所以谢谢你们。
Ah, Max, thank you so much for sending in these audio clips. You made my day. That's great. Well, you know, Jenna, I read the shoot. draft of this episode, and the interns actually had some different names. Oh. So, Mori, who is Mori, was actually spilled M-O-R-I. Okay.
啊，马克斯，非常感谢你发来这些音频片段。你让我今天过得很开心。太棒了。嗯，你知道吗，珍娜，我读了这一集的拍摄剧本，实习生们其实有不同的名字。哦。所以，莫里，也就是莫里，其实拼写是M-O-R-I。好的。
And then in the episode that aired, you'll see it quoted as M-A-U-R-I-E. But it was actually spilled M-O-R-I in the shooting draft. Okay. And then Megan's name was actually Maria. Oh. And Eric was Eric. Oh. So all through the shooting draft, I was reading it, and I kept being like, who is Maria?
然后在播出的那一集中，你会看到它拼写为M-A-U-R-I-E。但在拍摄剧本中它确实是拼写为M-O-R-I。好的。然后梅根的名字其实是玛丽亚。哦。而埃里克就是埃里克。哦。所以在整个拍摄剧本中，我一直在读，我一直在想，玛丽亚是谁？
Well, the interns are going to spark some gossip. They are. And I have two background catches in this scene. We have Oscar, Meredith, and Kelly speculating about this relationship between Eric and Megan. If you go to two minutes, 34 seconds, I am calling this the green scene. Oh. Because Kelly has on a green sweater. Meredith has on a green cardigan.
嗯，实习生们要引发一些八卦了。他们会的。我在这一幕中有两个背景捕捉。我们有奥斯卡、梅雷迪斯和凯利在推测埃里克和梅根之间的这种关系。如果你看到2分34秒，我把这称为“绿色场景”。哦。因为凯利穿着一件绿色毛衣。梅雷迪斯穿着一件绿色开衫。
Megan has on a green blouse. and there is a turquoise green lunch bag on the table. Oh, green scene. Green scene. Green in the break room. Green in the break room. And then at 2 minutes, 34 seconds, Megan and Eric are at a file cabinet by this back door,
梅根穿着一件绿色衬衫，桌上有一个绿松石色的午餐袋。哦，绿色场景。绿色场景。休息室里有绿色。休息室里有绿色。然后在2分34秒，梅根和埃里克在后门旁的文件柜边，
sort of on the other side of the partition by Kelly's desk clump. Yes. That file cabinet has never been used. Are they using it for the first time? Groundbreaking moment, everyone. Wow. First time file cabinet usage. So what happens here is that people are speculating
就在凯利办公桌群隔断的另一边。是的。那个文件柜从来没用过。他们是第一次用吗？开创性的时刻，各位。哇。第一次使用文件柜。所以这里发生的事情是，人们在推测
if Eric and Megan are going to get married. And if they are hooking up. Right. Yeah. And Michael starts to feel very proud because he introduced them. Wait, can I just say I have my favorite line of this whole entire episode in this scene? I can't believe it's in this scene because I have a favorite line and it's later. Okay.
埃里克和梅根是否要结婚了。以及他们是否在搞暧昧。对。是的。迈克尔开始感到非常自豪，因为是他介绍他们认识的。等等，我能说我在这一幕里有我整集最喜欢的台词吗？我不敢相信它在这一幕里，因为我有一个最喜欢的台词是在后面。好的。
Go on. Well, Kelly is like upset at the idea that they might get married before she would, right? Michael walks in and says, who's getting married? Pam says nobody. And here's my favorite line. Michael says, if somebody doesn't tell me, I'm going to start screaming. Oh, that is good. I was just like, who says that? And you know, they know he will. Ultimately, Phyllis says, Michael, there's nothing really to know. It's just gossip. Well, of course, Michael is now going to tailspin that he's been left out. Yeah, other people know gossip he didn't know. But before we move on to that, I have some background catches in the break room as well.
继续。嗯，凯利对他们可能比她先结婚的想法感到不安，对吧？迈克尔走进来问，谁要结婚了？帕姆说没人。这是我最喜欢的台词。迈克尔说，如果有人不告诉我，我就要开始尖叫了。哦，那太棒了。我当时就想，谁会这么说？而且你知道，他们知道他会这么做。最终，菲利斯说，迈克尔，真的没什么可知道的。这只是八卦。嗯，当然，迈克尔现在要因为被排除在外而陷入崩溃了。是的，其他人知道他不知道的八卦。但在我们继续之前，我在休息室也有一些背景捕捉。
well. Okay. It's called, what is everyone eating? Phyllis is having a salad. She's eating something with a fork. I am definitely eating a salad with a side of grapes. Oscar's food is blocked, but I think it might be a sandwich. Meredith is eating yogurt. Stanley has a very substantial sandwich and chips and a Fuji water bottle with the label facing away from camera. You're obsessed. I'm obsessed. But the food I want you to concentrate on is John Krasinski's food. Did you screen grab it? When I first saw it, it looked like a container of shredded chicken.
好的。这叫，大家在吃什么？菲利斯在吃沙拉。她正用叉子吃东西。我绝对是在吃沙拉配葡萄。奥斯卡的食物被挡住了，但我认为那可能是一个三明治。梅雷迪斯在吃酸奶。斯坦利有一个非常扎实的三明治和薯片，还有一瓶富士水，标签背对着镜头。你真是着迷了。我着迷了。但我希望你关注的食物是约翰·卡拉辛斯基的食物。你截图了吗？当我第一次看到它时，它看起来像是一盒手撕鸡肉。
What? But it's not. There's no fork. So I really zoomed in. And what it is is it is a sandwich that he has picked out the middle of and left the crusts. It's like he ate it from the. inside out. It is the weirdest thing. Are we finding out right now that Jim is actually the person that eats like a squirrel and not Angela Martin? I think so. But you know, for a scene like this,
什么？但它不是。没有叉子。所以我真的放大了看。它是一个三明治，他把中间掏空了，留下了面包皮。就像他是从里到外吃的一样。这是最奇怪的事情。我们现在是不是发现吉姆其实是那个像松鼠一样吃东西的人，而不是安吉拉·马丁？我想是的。但你知道，对于这样的一幕，
it would just say in the script, they're in the break room having lunch. And Phil Shea would have to go around to all of us and ask us what we wanted to eat in the scene. And for me, depending on how close it was to actual lunch, I would either pick a substantial meal or something small. So I'm eating a salad and some grapes. That is not a meal to me. So we must have shot this after lunch because I was like, you know what, I will have already eaten just give me something light. They were always very mindful that my character was a vegetarian. So I often would be eating fruit or a salad or some kind of veggies or chips or something. I'm going to need a picture of that gym sandwich. Thank you very much. Got to take a picture of it for me.
剧本里只会写，他们在休息室吃午饭。菲尔·谢伊必须走到我们每个人身边，问我们在这一幕里想吃什么。对我来说，取决于离真正的午餐有多近，我会选择一顿丰盛的午餐或是一些小东西。所以我吃的是沙拉和一些葡萄。那对我来说不是一顿饭。所以我们一定是在午餐后拍的，因为我当时想，你知道吗，我已经吃过了，给我点清淡的就行。他们总是非常注意我的角色是个素食主义者。所以我经常会吃水果、沙拉、某种蔬菜或薯片之类的东西。我需要一张那个吉姆三明治的照片。非常感谢。得帮我拍张照。
I'll show you. It's so odd. We're going to now have a Pam and Jim talking head where basically what we're doing here is we are confirming that what you knew from the season finale episode that Pam is pregnant. But they're also going to let you know they have not told anyone in the office. Yeah, I loved it when Jim was like, you know, the yakety yacks in this office, they'll have a field day. So this is true, but they're keeping it to themselves. That's what you need to know. Michael's determined to get to the bottom of this gossip.
我会给你看的。太奇怪了。我们现在要进行一个帕姆和吉姆的谈话头，基本上我们在这里做的是确认你在季终集里知道的事情，帕姆怀孕了。但他们也会让你知道他们还没有告诉办公室里的任何人。是的，我喜欢吉姆说，你知道，办公室里的那些长舌妇，他们会乐坏的。所以这是真的，但他们自己保守着这个秘密。这就是你需要知道的。迈克尔决心要查清这个八卦的真相。
He goes to Dwight, and Dwight knew all of it. Yeah. Oh, this is going to make Michael spiral even more. He has this great talking head. And Jenna, Steve could not get through this. The one about the poop ball? He couldn't get through it. And Steve rarely broke.
他去找德怀特，德怀特全都知道。是的。哦，这会让迈克尔更加抓狂。他有一个很棒的谈话头。而且珍娜，史蒂夫没法顺利演完这一段。就是关于“便便球”的那段？他没法演完。史蒂夫很少笑场。
Here's the blooper. It just makes me laugh hearing Steve. And you hear Paul Lieberstein laughing. I hate, hate, hate being left out, whether it's for a sport or like not being picked for a team or being picked for a team and then showing up and realizing that the team doesn't exist or that the sport doesn't exist. I should have known, poop ball. So great. They're like little kids. I know.
这是花絮。听到史蒂夫笑让我自己也笑了。你还能听到保罗·利伯斯坦在笑。我讨厌，讨厌，讨厌被排除在外，无论是为了运动，还是像没被选进球队，或者被选进球队后出现却发现球队根本不存在，或者运动根本不存在。我早该知道的，便便球。太棒了。他们就像小孩子一样。我知道。
They couldn't get through the word poop ball. I loved it every time Steve got tickled like that. Michael is now going to corner Mori in the kitchen. Mori is making coffee. He has to know about this rumor about Eric and Megan. So he's like, was it hard to be the third wheel on their group date? And Mori's like, no. And Michael's like, you know, my mom said the third wheel is what makes it a tricycle.
他们没法顺利说出“便便球”这个词。我喜欢史蒂夫每次被逗乐的样子。迈克尔现在要在厨房里堵住莫里。莫里正在煮咖啡。他必须知道关于埃里克和梅根的传闻。所以他问，在他们的集体约会中当电灯泡很难吗？莫里说，不。迈克尔说，你知道，我妈妈说电灯泡（第三个轮子）才是让它变成三轮车的原因。
My gosh. Oh, Michael. So basically what happens in the scene is that Mori is going to reveal that Stanley was also at this club with his wife and that Mori tried to wave at Stanley, but Stanley didn't wave back. Well, this is new information. Michael is thrilled. He knows something. Stanley was at a club. Yeah.
天哪。哦，迈克尔。所以这一幕里发生的事情基本上是，莫里要透露斯坦利当时也和他的妻子在那个俱乐部，莫里试图向斯坦利挥手，但斯坦利没有回挥。嗯，这是新信息。迈克尔很兴奋。他知道了一些事。斯坦利在俱乐部。是的。
Big news. Big news. Not just any club, but Tinks. Yeah. Tinks. Tinks. Tinks club. Michael would have had a talking.
大新闻。大新闻。不是随便什么俱乐部，而是Tinks。是的。Tinks。Tinks俱乐部。迈克尔本来会有一个谈话头。
head here that got cut. It was in the shooting draft where he says, I know tinks. I go there every Friday night. Well, I wait in line there. You meet a lot of fun people online. I've never been inside, but I wouldn't want. Online or in line. Sorry. Online. Okay, sorry. Go ahead. Okay. You made a lot of fun people online. I've never been inside, but I wouldn't want to. It's for people half my age. Part of me just wants to give up online dating all together. I really hate when Friday night rolls around. Wait. there's so much there. He thinks online dating as you go and stand in a long line at a nightclub. Oh my gosh.
在这里被剪掉了。在拍摄剧本里他说，我知道Tinks。我每个周五晚上都去那儿。嗯，我在那儿排队。你在网上（online）能遇到很多有趣的人。我从来没进去过，但我不想。网上还是排队（in line）。抱歉。网上。好的，抱歉。继续。好的。你在网上能遇到很多有趣的人。我从来没进去过，但我不想。那是给只有我一半大的人去的。我的一部分只想彻底放弃网上约会。周五晚上到来时我真的很讨厌。等等。那里信息量太大了。他以为网上约会就是你去夜总会排长队。天哪。
Come on, isn't that so good? That is so good. Between Mori talking about Tinks and me reading about this deleted talking head where Michael talks about Tinks, I had to know. Is Tinks a real place? And by the way, it is. It was a total hotspot, Jenna. But here's the thing.
拜托，这难道不好吗？这太好了。在莫里谈论Tinks和我读到这个被删掉的迈克尔谈论Tinks的谈话头之间，我必须知道。Tinks是一个真实的地方吗？顺便说一下，是的。它曾经是一个绝对的热点，珍娜。但问题是。
While I was researching that, I got so fascinated with the history of the building that Tinks was in. I have to share about it. I took a picture. I'll put it in stories. Look at this place, Jenna. Right there in the middle. That's where Tinks would have been. This looks very, I feel like I'm looking at a picture of London.
当我在研究那个的时候，我对Tinks所在建筑的历史非常着迷。我必须分享一下。我拍了一张照片。我会把它发到故事里。看看这个地方，珍娜。就在中间。那就是Tinks曾经所在的地方。这看起来非常，我觉得我像是在看一张伦敦的照片。
I know. It looks old, right? It looks old English to me. I found a great article on the Scranton Times Tributes website written by Brian Fulton. Brian, I loved all your info. Here's some of it, okay. The location of Tinks is 519, Linden Street, and Scranton. It was constructed in 1909. It looks old. I know. It was the Courthouse Square Garage, which sold Studebakers and EFM automobiles over the years. It would be a series of dealerships. It went on to be an electric appliance store, sporting goods stores.
我知道。看起来很古老，对吧？对我来说看起来像古老的英式风格。我在《斯克兰顿时报》网站上找到了一篇布莱恩·富尔顿写的很棒的文章。布莱恩，我喜欢你所有的信息。这是其中的一些，好吗。Tinks的位置是斯克兰顿林登街519号。它建于1909年。看起来很老。我知道。它曾经是法院广场车库，多年来销售斯图贝克和EFM汽车。它会是一系列经销商。后来它成了电器商店、体育用品商店。
In the mid-20s, it became the Scranton Recreation. It offered a bowling alley, a billiard room on the third floor. 30 years later, in the 50s, René Dress operated on the building second floor. Then the Linden Dress Corporation bought the whole building, expanding to the third floor with retail and dining establishments on the ground floor. In 1988, it was going to have an open-air cafe, a new banquet hall that could see. seat 150 and the creation of a dinner theater. Oh.
20年代中期，它成了斯克兰顿娱乐中心。它提供保龄球馆，三楼有台球室。30年后，在50年代，勒内礼服店在二楼经营。然后林登礼服公司买下了整栋楼，扩展到三楼，底层有零售和餐饮场所。1988年，它要有一个露天咖啡馆，一个新的宴会厅，可以容纳150人，并创建一个晚餐剧院。哦。
Yes. The first dinner theater production to take place was called Nifty 50s, a musical review. Then they started offering live music on Tuesdays and Sundays. In 1994, they sold tinks to John, Paul, and Angela Cooper, operators of Cooper's Seafood House in Scranton. Oh. The venue remained a popular night spot in Scranton. It was a hub for live music for years.
是的。第一个上演的晚餐剧院作品叫《俏皮50年代》，一个音乐评论。然后他们开始在周二和周日提供现场音乐。1994年，他们把Tinks卖给了约翰、保罗和安吉拉·库珀，斯克兰顿库珀海鲜屋的经营者。哦。这个场地仍然是斯克兰顿受欢迎的夜生活场所。多年来它一直是现场音乐的中心。
All these amazing bands would come through. And then in the fall of 2015, it became Levels on Linden. And they closed March of this year. But it started out as a car garage selling Studebakers. I'll tell you that I got really stopped. You know when someone's telling you a story and you hear a part of that story and then your brain? kind of goes in another place. When you said Nifty 50s musical review...
所有这些很棒的乐队都会来这里。然后在2015年秋天，它变成了林登的Levels。今年三月关门了。但它最初是一个卖斯图贝克的汽车车库。我得告诉你，我真的被难住了。你知道当有人给你讲故事，你听到故事的一部分，然后你的大脑？有点去了别的地方。当你提到《俏皮50年代》音乐评论时……
You could only think of Andy Bernard. No, I could only think of you and I doing the Nifty 50s dinner theater musical review and what that might be. And I'm going to be honest with you, I went off on that for a while in my head. But I made it back to hear that the Cooper's people bought it.
你只能想到安迪·伯纳德。不，我只能想到你和我做《俏皮50年代》晚餐剧院音乐评论，那会是什么样子。老实说，我在脑子里想了很久。但我回过神来听到库珀家的人买下了它。
And then it was a series, of nightclubs and it closed this year. Okay. So I guess it's available. It's available. Angel and Jenna's musical theater review. I'm just saying. Oh my gosh.
然后它是一系列夜总会，今年关门了。好的。所以我猜它现在空着。它空着。安吉拉和珍娜的音乐剧评论。我只是说说。天哪。
Nifty 50s. Nifty 50s. I mean, has anything been more made for us? Well, I just turned 50. I think we wait for you to turn 50 in a few years. Yeah. And then we go do the nifty 50s. Yes.
《俏皮50年代》。《俏皮50年代》。我的意思是，还有什么比这更适合我们的吗？嗯，我刚满50岁。我想我们等你几年后满50岁。是的。然后我们去演《俏皮50年代》。是的。
That's all I've been thinking about since you said it. I love the history of old buildings. I absolutely love it. I love to think about the different people that came in and out of that space. Yeah. And the memories that were made, whether you were buying your very first car and it was a studebaker, or you were doing dinner theater. Or you were getting a dress made. Yes. Or you were meeting your lady love for a rendezvous, Stanley. Well, when Stanley leaves the office, Michael is so excited to share what he thinks he's learned, which is that Stanley is having a midlife crisis. Yeah. Because he was out at this club.
自从你说了之后，我一直在想这个。我喜欢老建筑的历史。我绝对喜欢。我喜欢思考那些进出那个空间的不同的人。是的。以及留下的记忆，无论你是买了你的第一辆车，它是一辆斯图贝克，还是你在做晚餐剧院。或者你在做一件礼服。是的。或者你在和你的爱人约会，斯坦利。嗯，当斯坦利离开办公室时，迈克尔非常兴奋地分享他认为他学到的东西，那就是斯坦利正在经历中年危机。是的。因为他去了这个俱乐部。
But Dwight says, no, Stanley is way past the middle of his life. And Phyllis is like, Michael, what you're saying isn't true because Terry is out of town and Stanley hates crowds. He hates kids. You should check your facts. We got some Phyllis sass. Well, Michael's going to march up to the interns. He's fired up. Jenna, I want you to know.
但德怀特说，不，斯坦利早就过了中年了。菲利斯说，迈克尔，你说的不是真的，因为特里出城了，而且斯坦利讨厌人群。他讨厌孩子。你应该核实一下事实。我们得到了一些菲利斯的讽刺。嗯，迈克尔要走向实习生们。他很兴奋。珍娜，我想让你知道。
This scene started differently in the shooting draft. Oh. Michael is still going to march up, but the interns are gossiping as he arrives. Oh. Uh-huh. It says interior break room, Mori, Eric, and Maria, because that's what she was called in a shooting draft, are in an assembly line style, unstapling and coelating and stapling. Michael barges in.
这一幕在拍摄剧本里开始得不一样。哦。迈克尔还是要走过去，但实习生们在他到达时正在八卦。哦。嗯哼。上面写着室内休息室，莫里、埃里克和玛丽亚，因为她在拍摄剧本里叫这个名字，正在流水线式地拆订书钉、整理和装订。迈克尔闯了进来。
Mori says, You see what Aaron's wearing today? Eric, I'm more of a Pam kind of guy. Maria, the warehouse guys were saying she's dated like everyone in the office. Oh my gosh! And then at this moment, Michael says, you stupid son of a bitch, you set me up. Well, this is when it finally occurs to Michael,
莫里说，你看到亚伦今天穿什么了吗？埃里克，我更喜欢帕姆那种类型的。玛丽亚，仓库的人说她和办公室里的每个人都约会过。天哪！就在这时，迈克尔说，你这个愚蠢的混蛋，你陷害我。嗯，这就是迈克尔终于意识到的时候，
after much explanation that perhaps Stanley was there with someone other than his wife. The amount of time it takes Michael to clue in on something. Oh my gosh. It's one of my favorite things. Yeah. Well, now Michael really has some gossip, and he is so excited to share it. He does not at all understand the gravity of what he's sharing and the damage it could do to multiple lives. He's just giddy to have a little tidbit of info.
经过很多解释，也许斯坦利当时和妻子以外的人在一起。迈克尔领悟某事所需的时间。天哪。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。是的。嗯，现在迈克尔真的有一些八卦了，他非常兴奋地分享它。他根本不理解他所分享的内容的严重性以及它可能对多个人生造成的伤害。他只是因为有一点点信息而感到头晕目眩。
He runs over to the biggest office gossip Kelly, and he says Stanley's having an affair. She's like, what? We had a fan catch from Sarah G in Ottawa. At around 6 minutes, 30 seconds, when Michael tells Kelly about Stanley's affair, there's a whiteboard behind her desk that reads people's names and numbers. It says sales quarterly sales and HR performance. Sarah notes, one, Pam is not on there, even though she is a single person. salesperson now, but Creed is. Sarah wants to know why is that. Sarah, I do not think that this whiteboard has been changed in like two seasons. For sure. Because I remember seeing this whiteboard in season three.
他跑到办公室最大的八卦凯利那里，说斯坦利有外遇。她说，什么？我们收到了来自渥太华莎拉·G的粉丝捕捉。在大约6分30秒，当迈克尔告诉凯利关于斯坦利的外遇时，她桌子后面有一个白板，上面写着人的名字和数字。上面写着销售季度销售和人力资源绩效。莎拉指出，第一，帕姆不在上面，尽管她现在是一个单身销售员，但克里德在。莎拉想知道为什么。莎拉，我不认为这个白板在过去两季里换过。肯定的。因为我记得在第三季看到过这个白板。
Andy is at the top. And I don't think I've seen this change in years. Well, to be fair, we were rarely over in that corner, so it might have gotten overlooked. Michael is determined to keep spreading this information. He is now trying to get Kevin to guess. Yes, he's playing that word guessing game Hangman. Yeah. Kevin's not getting it. No, Kevin's not getting it. Lady, this reminded me of Wheel of Fortune. Because Wheel of Fortune is based on this game. Oh, yeah. You guess a phrase. My family was obsessed with Wheel of Fortune. We had the home game. The Wheel of Fortune home. game. And my mom, bless her heart, was a horrible guesser. Just horrible. Our favorite family example, you know when you have those things that happen in your family that go down as like your family
安迪在最上面。我不认为我多年来见过这个有变化。嗯，公平地说，我们很少去那个角落，所以它可能被忽略了。迈克尔决心继续传播这些信息。他现在正试图让凯文猜。是的，他在玩那个猜词游戏“刽子手”。是的。凯文猜不到。不，凯文猜不到。女士，这让我想起了《幸运轮》。因为《幸运轮》就是基于这个游戏的。哦，是的。你猜一个短语。我的家人对《幸运轮》着迷。我们有家庭游戏。《幸运轮》家庭游戏。我妈妈，保佑她的心，是一个糟糕的猜谜者。简直太糟糕了。我们最喜欢的家庭例子，你知道当你的家庭里发生那些被当作你们家庭
lore? Sure, sure. Okay. We were playing this game. My mom's trying to guess the phrase. And she screams out of nowhere. I've got it. I've got it. Gold tooth tiger. We're like, Mom, Gold-toothed tiger? What is this famous phrase, gold-toothed tiger? I don't remember what it was. It was not gold-toothed tiger. Of course not. So anyway, now that's like my...
传说的事情吗？当然，当然。好的。我们在玩这个游戏。我妈妈在试图猜这个短语。她突然尖叫起来。我猜到了。我猜到了。金牙老虎。我们就像，妈妈，金牙老虎？这个著名的短语“金牙老虎”是什么？我不记得那是什么了。那不是金牙老虎。当然不是。所以无论如何，现在那就像我的……
A catchphrase. Gold-toothed tiger. My sister and I can be like gold-tooth tiger, mom. But my sister and I became obsessed, and we researched the most common letters in the English language. Wait, isn't one that you're always supposed to guess like S or T? T is one. Okay, T. I'll tell you, here are the 12 most commonly occurring letters in the English language.
口头禅。金牙老虎。我和我姐姐可以像，金牙老虎，妈妈。但我姐姐和我变得着迷，我们研究了英语中最常见的字母。等等，不是有一个你总是应该猜的，比如S或T？T是一个。好的，T。我告诉你，这是英语中最常见的12个字母。
From most to least. E. Okay. T, A, O, I, N, S, H, R, D, L, U. So if you're ever on Wheel of Fortune, and you're going to buy a vowel, buy an E. Okay. If you're going to guess a consonant, the first one you should guess is T. And the second one is N.
从最多到最少。E。好的。T、A、O、I、N、S、H、R、D、L、U。所以如果你在《幸运轮》上，你要买一个元音，买一个E。好的。如果你要猜一个辅音，你应该猜的第一个是T。第二个是N。
I didn't know that, but I feel like some of it just mushed into my brain because my grandmother faithfully watched Will of Fortune every single day. It was one of her favorite shows. She was so good. She could guess way before everyone else. We used to joke, Grandmother, you've got to go on Will of Fortune. She's like, oh, no, I am not going to be on television. No.
我不知道那个，但我感觉其中一些只是混进了我的大脑，因为我祖母每天都忠实地看《幸运轮》。这是她最喜欢的节目之一。她太厉害了。她能在所有人之前猜出来。我们过去常开玩笑，祖母，你得去参加《幸运轮》。她说，哦，不，我才不要上电视。不。
And she loved Pat Sejack. and Vana White. They could do no wrong. Oh. And she knew everything about them. Yes, same. My family was obsessed. I love it. Just to close this out, I can also tell you the most difficult words to guess. Oh, really?
她喜欢帕特·萨贾克和凡娜·怀特。他们不会做错任何事。哦。她知道关于他们的一切。是的，一样。我的家人着迷了。我喜欢它。为了结束这个话题，我还可以告诉你最难猜的词。哦，真的吗？
Yeah. This was according to a 2010 study conducted by John McLune for Wolfram Research. Ooh. Why Wolfram Research decided to conduct the survey, I don't know. I don't know, but I appreciate it. But the five most difficult words to guess in a word guessing game are jazz, buzz, two Z's, Haj, Fizz, and Fuzz. People are not good at guessing Z words.
是的。这是根据约翰·麦克伦为沃尔夫勒姆研究公司在2010年进行的一项研究。噢。为什么沃尔夫勒姆研究公司决定进行这项调查，我不知道。我不知道，但我很感激。但在猜词游戏中五个最难猜的词是jazz（爵士乐）、buzz（嗡嗡声，两个Z）、Haj（朝觐）、Fizz（嘶嘶声）和Fuzz（绒毛）。人们不擅长猜Z开头的词。
I guess not. Yeah, I guess you can use that information if you want. It will not help you to guess E-T-A-N-S-H-R-D-L-U. I mean, if the caption is like hot fuzz, juzhing jazz. You're like... Well, no one's going to be able to guess that.
我想不是。是的，我想如果你愿意，你可以使用这些信息。它不会帮你猜E-T-A-N-S-H-R-D-L-U。我的意思是，如果标题是像“热血警探”（Hot Fuzz），调整爵士乐（juzhing jazz）。你会觉得……嗯，没人能猜到那个。
Nope. Make that your phrase. That's your gold-toothed stumber. That's your stumper. Michael is going to try to intercept Stanley as he's on his way
不。把它作为你的短语。那是你的“金牙老虎”。那是你的难题。迈克尔要试图拦截斯坦利，当他正要去
to meet with a client. He asked him if he knows a beautiful woman who can dance for a movie Michael is casting. It's going to pay $5 million.
见客户时。他问他是否认识一个能为迈克尔正在选角的电影跳舞的美丽女人。它将支付500万美元。
Some nudity required. Stanley leaves And then Jim comes to the window and he's like, Michael, you need to stop. You have to stop this. You have no proof that Stanley is having an affair. You might be ruining Stanley's life. Yeah. We had a fan question, Angela, from Alice R in Italy, who said, at around 7 minutes, 10 seconds,
需要一些裸露。斯坦利离开了，然后吉姆走到窗边说，迈克尔，你需要停止。你必须停止这样做。你没有任何证据表明斯坦利有外遇。你可能会毁了斯坦利的生活。是的。安吉拉，我们有一个来自意大利爱丽丝·R的粉丝问题，她说，在大约7分10秒，
when Michael is talking to Stanley and then Jim, through the side window of his office, Aaron is sitting in the background. The whole time. And then Allie W from Canada said, is there a deleted scene that a explains why Aaron is there. There isn't one on the DVDs, but I can tell you in the shooting draft at the end of this scene, Aaron had one line. What was it? As Michael considers and runs out passing by Aaron, Aaron says, is that the end of the letter? Oh, so she was in there. Possibly he was dictating a letter to her to write to someone. Oh, so good. Lady, I think we should take a break
当迈克尔通过他办公室的侧窗和斯坦利然后吉姆说话时，亚伦一直坐在背景里。一直都在。然后来自加拿大的艾莉·W说，有没有删减片段解释为什么亚伦在那里。DVD上没有，但我可以告诉你，在这一幕结束时的拍摄剧本里，亚伦有一句台词。是什么？当迈克尔考虑并跑出去经过亚伦时，亚伦说，那是信的结尾吗？哦，所以她在那里。可能他正在口述一封信让她写给某人。哦，太棒了。女士，我想我们应该休息一下
because the scene coming up when Michael runs out and gets in Stanley's car, I have a lot to say. It's so good. It's so good. We'll be right back. Michael runs into the parking lot. He stops Stanley from driving away by throwing himself in front of Stanley's car, and then he says, are you having an affair? Cut two, now he's in the car. Right. And believe it or not, Stanley admits he's having an affair with Cynthia, his nurse. They had a lot of long walks on the treadmill together. You know, Terry's been traveling so much.
因为接下来迈克尔跑出去上斯坦利车的那一幕，我有很多话要说。太棒了。太棒了。我们马上回来。迈克尔跑进停车场。他通过把自己扔在斯坦利车前阻止斯坦利开车离开，然后他说，你有外遇吗？切到，现在他在车里了。对。信不信由你，斯坦利承认他和他的护士辛西娅有外遇。他们在跑步机上一起走了很长的路。你知道，特里出差太多了。
He's been lonely. Michael is still not getting it. But then Stanley is like, I'm actually on my way to break it off with Cynthia right now. And Michael is like, wait a second. You said you were going on a sales call. Do people do that all the time? Do they tell me they're going on sales calls and they go somewhere else? Oh, Michael.
他一直很孤独。迈克尔还是没明白。但后来斯坦利说，我其实正要去和辛西娅分手。迈克尔说，等一下。你说你要去进行销售拜访。人们总是那样做吗？他们告诉我他们要去进行销售拜访，然后他们去了别的地方？哦，迈克尔。
And then Michael is like, wow, it's true. He finally gets it. And Stanley's like, listen, you cannot tell us. anyone about this, please. I'm counting on you. So in the shooting of the scene, Angela, I counted four cameras. We usually only have two cameras, but I counted four different camera angles. Give it to me, lady. Where'd you see them? To cover this scene. So the first one is shooting from up above, out of the office, down onto the parking lot. Then we have the bulk of the scene, which is shooting either through the window on Stanley's side
然后迈克尔说，哇，是真的。他终于明白了。斯坦利说，听着，你不能告诉任何人这件事，拜托。我指望你了。所以在这一幕的拍摄中，安吉拉，我数了四台摄像机。我们通常只有两台摄像机，但我数了四个不同的摄像机角度。给我，女士。你在哪里看到的？为了覆盖这一幕。所以第一个是从上面拍摄，从办公室外面，向下对着停车场。然后我们有这一幕的大部分，要么是通过斯坦利那一侧的窗户拍摄
or the other side shooting through the window on Michael's side. So that's three. But then for one second, right around eight minutes, 27 seconds, there is this spy shot that is straight on. And it's sort of through some leaves. Mm-hmm. Well, Randy told me that this was a trick. There's nothing there.
或者另一侧通过迈克尔那一侧的窗户拍摄。所以那是三个。但随后有一秒钟，在大约8分27秒，有一个直拍的间谍镜头。它有点穿过一些叶子。嗯哼。嗯，兰迪告诉我这是一个把戏。那里什么都没有。
Faky tree? Faky tree. Yes. They took a leafy branch and they put it on a grip stand and then someone would shake it a little bit to make it seem like there was a breeze. And Matt composed his shot to include some of those leaves so that it would look like a spy shot. Why in my brain do I hear someone like on a walkie-talkie going shake it a little less? Yes, too much movement. Too much shaking. Shake it up higher. Shake it, shake it lower. Now, I don't know if Randy was teasing me, but he told me the technical term for this is called a branchaloros. Come on. He said it's often used in outdoor shooting. Come on, is that true?
假树？假树。是的。他们拿了一个多叶的树枝，把它放在一个抓地架上，然后有人会轻轻摇动它，让它看起来好像有微风。马特构图了这个镜头，包括了一些叶子，这样它看起来就像一个间谍镜头。为什么我的大脑里听到有人像在对讲机上说“摇得少一点”？是的，动作太多了。摇晃太多了。往高处摇。摇，往低处摇。现在，我不知道兰迪是不是在逗我，但他告诉我这个术语叫“branchaloros”（树枝戏法）。拜托。他说它经常用于户外拍摄。拜托，那是真的吗？
I don't know. Randy, a branchaloros? Is he listening to our podcast? Just laughing. They bought it. Branchaloris. That's so fun. If I'm ever directing Randy and I call for a branchalores and people don't know what I'm talking about, I'm calling you.
我不知道。兰迪，一个“branchaloros”？他在听我们的播客吗？只是在笑。他们上当了。“Branchaloris”。太有趣了。如果我以后指导兰迪，我要求一个“branchalores”，而人们不知道我在说什么，我就给你打电话。
Well, Michael is going to promise Stanley that he. won't say anything, but we already know it's too late for that. So now he comes up with this crazy idea that what he has to do is diffuse that one piece of information by just throwing out all kinds of rumors. Yeah. He finds Kevin in the kitchen making cookies. Yeah, he's making cookies in the toaster oven. Mm-hmm. Michael says, have you heard about Angela dating an 81-year-old billionaire who owns a quiz knows? Then he goes up to reception and he tells Aaron that Kevin. Lily is an anorexic. Did you notice at 10 minutes, 25 seconds, that Aaron's little desk area has a Keystone College
嗯，迈克尔要向斯坦利保证他。不会说什么，但我们已经知道现在说这个太晚了。所以现在他想出了这个疯狂的主意，他必须通过抛出各种各样的谣言来化解那一条信息。是的。他在厨房里发现凯文在做饼干。是的，他在烤箱里做饼干。嗯哼。迈克尔说，你听说安吉拉在和一个拥有Quiznos的81岁亿万富翁约会吗？然后他走到接待处，告诉亚伦凯文。莉莉是个厌食症患者。你注意到在10分25秒，亚伦的小办公桌区域有一个基斯通学院
little banner? Yes. And a teddy bear with a red hoodie. I got real interested in her reception desk, Angela. Oh, did you? You and I obviously were thinking the same thing because when I saw that Keystone College banner, I was like, hold up. I want to know more about Aaron.
小横幅吗？是的。还有一个穿着红色连帽衫的泰迪熊。我对她的接待台真的很感兴趣，安吉拉。哦，是吗？你和我显然在想同样的事情，因为当我看到那个基斯通学院的横幅时，我就想，等等。我想更多地了解亚伦。
What will her desk reveal? What did you find? Well, Keystone College is a real private college in northwestern Pennsylvania. And not only does she have a stuffed dog with a little sweater, that little sweater says J-Rob. And then she has a pink ski boot mug that she has put her pens and pencils in, and that also says J-Rob. What is J-Rob? I googled it, and it is a wrestling camp in Pennsylvania. Get out.
她的桌子会揭示什么？你发现了什么？嗯，基斯通学院是宾夕法尼亚州西北部的一所真正的私立学院。而且她不仅有一个穿着小毛衣的毛绒狗，那件小毛衣上写着J-Rob。然后她有一个粉红色的滑雪靴杯，她把笔和铅笔放在里面，上面也写着J-Rob。J-Rob是什么？我谷歌了一下，它是宾夕法尼亚州的一个摔跤训练营。滚开。
I don't think this is correct. Why they would sell a ski boot. I looked at all their merch for this wrestling camp. I don't even think the logo is the same. Did Aaron go to wrestling camp? I am very stumped on this one. I don't know. But Aaron also has a candy dish with some individually wrapped lifesavers in it.
我不认为这是正确的。他们为什么要卖滑雪靴。我看了他们这个摔跤训练营的所有周边。我甚至不认为标志是一样的。亚伦去过摔跤训练营吗？我对此感到非常困惑。我不知道。但亚伦还有一个糖果盘，里面有一些独立包装的救生圈糖。
Phil Shea, what is J. Rob? What is J. Rob? And then I was like, is it J. Rub, like, J.R. B, or is it J.R. O B? I googled both. But there is a wrestling camp. in Pennsylvania called J-Rob. Okay. Michael's going to continue his rumor mill.
菲尔·谢伊，J. Rob是什么？J. Rob是什么？然后我就想，是J. Rub，像J.R. B，还是J.R. O B？我两个都谷歌了。但有一个摔跤训练营。在宾夕法尼亚州叫J-Rob。好的。迈克尔要继续他的谣言工厂。
He's going to tell Kelly that Aaron isn't a very good worker and may not last long at Dundra Mifflin and that Andy is gay. He tells Meredith that Pam is pregnant. So he's really throwing a lot of stuff out there. Of course, we know, oh my gosh, Pam is pregnant. Yeah. Well, now the rumors are just traveling. All crazy throughout the office.
他要告诉凯利亚伦不是一个很好的员工，可能在邓德·米夫林待不久，而且安迪是同性恋。他告诉梅雷迪斯帕姆怀孕了。所以他真的抛出了很多东西。当然，我们知道，天哪，帕姆怀孕了。是的。嗯，现在谣言正在传播。在整个办公室里疯狂传播。
Yes. And now people are going to start hearing the rumors about themselves. Yeah. Andy hears this rumor that he might be gay. From Kevin, and he's like, was this broccoli rob? Yes. Was it someone in high school? This sends Andy on an existential crisis, and he's going to confront Oscar in the break room.
是的。现在人们要开始听到关于他们自己的谣言了。是的。安迪听到了这个关于他可能是同性恋的谣言。从凯文那里，他说，那是西兰花罗布吗？是的。是高中里的某个人吗？这让安迪陷入了存在主义危机，他要在休息室里和奥斯卡对质。
Oscar has such a great talking head after that scene with Andy where he's like, what, it's my responsibility to comfort the insecure heterosexual men? That can't possibly fall on me. I'm paraphrasing it, but it's something like that. It's so good. When Andy is describing this scenario, where Brad Pitt is like coming on to him. At like a beach cabana.
奥斯卡在安迪那一幕之后有一个很棒的谈话头，他说，什么，安慰不安全的异性恋男人是我的责任吗？那不可能落在我身上。我在转述它，但大概就是那样。太棒了。当安迪描述这个场景时，布拉德·皮特像是在勾引他。在像海滩小屋那样的地方。
Yes, and Brad Pitt is trying to kiss him. And Andy resists, but Brad Pitt keeps coming for him. Oscar has this amazing line where he says, So if you resisted Brad Pitt a little bit, he would still need to get to you. Lady, the mention of Brad Pitt made me very randomly think about how I have had recurring dreams about Brad Pitt making me soup. What?
是的，布拉德·皮特试图吻他。安迪反抗，但布拉德·皮特一直向他靠近。奥斯卡有一句很棒的台词，他说，所以如果你反抗布拉德·皮特一点点，他仍然需要得到你。女士，提到布拉德·皮特让我非常随机地想到我曾反复梦见布拉德·皮特给我做汤。什么？
He makes me soup. What does this mean? Recurring dream. Like over your life? Yes. Like since college. What? And Brad Pitt would make me a warm, comforting bowl of soup.
他给我做汤。这是什么意思？反复的梦。就像你的一生？是的。就像从大学开始。什么？布拉德·皮特会给我做一碗温暖、舒适的汤。
And it would make me happy. And he was my friend in my dreams. Was he fully clothed? Yes. It was just a wonderful gesture. So I looked up, you know, dreams and meaning of dreams. What does it mean if you have soup? in your dream. Well, what a celebrity in your dream is, is that the celebrity is you. It's like a
这会让我快乐。他在我的梦里是我的朋友。他穿戴整齐吗？是的。这只是一个美妙的姿态。所以我查了，你知道，梦和梦的意义。如果你梦见汤是什么意思？在你的梦里。嗯，梦里的名人是什么，名人就是你自己。就像一个
version of you. So you're Brad Pitt, and you're making yourself soup? I guess so, but more than that, here's what I determined it to be. Okay. Brad Pitt is from Missouri. He's from where I grew up. So I think he was the big local celebrity when you were growing up. He went to Missouri, which was the college about an hour and a half away from my college. He didn't finish, but then he went off and he became a big star. You know, I've never met him. I've never been able to geek out with him about our Missouri roots, but it was a big deal. Like when you're from Missouri and someone else from Missouri is super famous, like everybody knows it, you know? Oh, man, I can never meet him now. Why? Because I know me. You're going to say something. And I know if I meet Brad Pitt, I won't be able to. It'll be like
你的版本？所以你是布拉德·皮特，你在给自己做汤？我想是的，但不仅如此，这就是我确定的。好的。布拉德·皮特来自密苏里州。他来自我长大的地方。所以我认为他是你长大时当地的大名人。他去了密苏里大学，那是离我大学大约一个半小时路程的大学。他没读完，但他离开了，成了一个大明星。你知道，我从来没见过他。我从来没能和他一起对我们的密苏里根源感到极客，但这是一件大事。就像当你来自密苏里州，而另一个来自密苏里州的人超级有名时，就像每个人都知道，你知道吗？哦，天哪，我现在永远见不到他了。为什么？因为我了解我。你会说些什么。我知道如果我见到布拉德·皮特，我将无法。那会像
a Michael Scott moment, I'll say, my friend Jena dreams that you make her soup. It'll just come tumbling out. I can never meet him. How can I ever meet him now when I know that my best friend, since college, his dream that he makes her soup? Here's what I think it is. I think he represents, like, whenever I felt homesick, I'll have a dream where, like, my hometown is making me soup.
一个迈克尔·斯科特的时刻，我会说，我的朋友珍娜梦见你给她做汤。它会脱口而出。我永远见不到他。当我得知我大学以来的好朋友梦见他给她做汤时，我怎么能见到他？这就是我认为的。我认为他代表，就像每当我感到想家时，我就会做一个梦，就像我的家乡在给我做汤。
Like, that's what I think it is. I think it's like a homesickness dream. I have never had a dream about Brad Pitt. Well, his soup is delicious. I just want to say, it's homemade. And it's very, very good. And it's always the soup is different. It's been, I remember very distinctly,
就像，这就是我认为的。我认为这就像一个想家的梦。我从来没梦见过布拉德·皮特。嗯，他的汤很美味。我只想说，它是自制的。而且非常，非常好。而且汤总是不同的。我记得非常清楚，
there was a vegetable and another time a cream of potato. I had a dream after I saw The Matrix that I could, you know, that I was like a badass with Keanu. And I was like, I could do all that stuff. Like I could fly a helicopter. Not quite the same. It's not quite the same. I don't know what that means.
有一次是蔬菜汤，另一次是奶油土豆汤。我在看了《黑客帝国》后做了一个梦，我能，你知道，我像基努一样是个坏蛋。我当时想，我能做所有那些事。就像我能开直升机。不太一样。不太一样。我不知道那是什么意思。
And I also have never had it again. I don't know. I haven't had this dream in a long time. Amazing. Amazing. Where were we? I don't know. It doesn't matter anymore.
而且我也再也没做过那个梦了。我不知道。我很久没做这个梦了。太棒了。太棒了。我们刚才在哪？我不知道。那不再重要了。
Brad Pitt makes you soup. Okay. We are at the point where now rumors are really spreading. Oh, here we are. I know where we are, lady. We're in the conference room, and we're giving the interns, they're letters of completion, and they're going to get some school credit. And there's cake.
布拉德·皮特给你做汤。好的。我们现在到了谣言真正传播的地步。哦，我们到了。我知道我们在哪，女士。我们在会议室，我们给实习生们他们的结业证书，他们要得到一些学分。还有蛋糕。
Fan catch from Sophia M. from Louisiana. Dwight is handing the interns a piece of paper to give them school credit, but in job fair, Michael says they cannot offer credit. Can you explain this? Sophia, I cannot explain it. I don't know. Maybe once Michael put Dwight in charge of it, it actually got done. Perhaps. I love that Dwight gives them his business card. He said, you can call me day or night. And then one of the interns says, why would I call you at night? Eric does. Yeah. And then he says, no, you can't call me at all. And Jim's like, well, good luck next time you're stuck between a moose and a bear. Between a moose and her cubs. Oh, and their cubs. Well, the rumors are coming out because people start commenting. For example, Aaron says to Kelly,
来自路易斯安那州索菲亚·M的粉丝提问。德怀特正在给实习生发一张纸，让他们获得学分，但在招聘会上，迈克尔说他们不能提供学分。你能解释一下吗？索菲亚，我无法解释。我不知道。也许一旦迈克尔让德怀特负责这件事，它就真的完成了。也许吧。我喜欢德怀特给他们名片的情节。他说，你可以日夜给我打电话。然后其中一个实习生说，我为什么要晚上给你打电话？埃里克会打。是的。然后他说，不，你根本不能给我打电话。吉姆说，好吧，祝你下次被困在驼鹿和熊之间时好运。在驼鹿和它的幼崽之间。哦，还有它们的幼崽。好吧，谣言开始传开了，因为人们开始评论。例如，亚伦对凯利说，
I'm so happy you're eating again. Yeah. And then Andy congratulates Jim on little baby tuna. Little Toro. Jim pulls Pam aside, and he's like, they know. I don't know how they know, but they know. This brings us to my favorite line of the show. What is it? Is it? I know what it is.
我真高兴你又开始吃东西了。是的。然后安迪祝贺吉姆有了小金枪鱼宝宝。小托罗。吉姆把帕姆拉到一边，他说，他们知道了。我不知道他们是怎么知道的，但他们知道了。这让我想到了我最喜欢的剧集台词。是什么？是吗？我知道是什么。
When Creed says someone is saying the rumor about Creed is that he has asthma. Yeah. And if that gets out, they're not going to let him scuba. And he has a talking head where he says, if he can't scuba, then what has all of this been about? What has he been working toward? I love it so much. I love the scuba talking head. I'm pretty sure I remember John breaking, though, when Creed said, they won't let me scuba.
当克里德说有人在传关于他的谣言，说他有哮喘。是的。如果这事传出去，他们就不会让他去潜水了。他有一个独白镜头，他说，如果他不能潜水，那这一切都是为了什么？他一直以来在努力追求什么？我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢那个关于潜水的独白。不过我很确定我记得约翰在克里德说“他们不会让我潜水”时笑场了。
Just Creed saying the word scuba. I would like to point out one thing in this scene. Many of you probably didn't catch it unless you've ever had a really horrible time growing out your bangs. If you go to 15 minutes, 07, you'll see my hair awkwardly trying to be. a ponytail, but it can't really be a ponytail because I decided to get bangs, and it took forever to grow them out. Look at this sad ponytail. I mean, I have to say, that looks like Pam's hair from seasons one through three. The little swoop that we used to do with my half bangs is what that reminds me of. Oh, bangs. Well, Oscar wants everyone to know he is not the voice of the Taco Bell dog.
仅仅是克里德说出“潜水”这个词。我想指出这个场景中的一件事。你们很多人可能没注意到，除非你曾经有过留刘海的糟糕经历。如果你看到15分07秒，你会看到我的头发尴尬地试图扎成马尾辫，但它实际上扎不成马尾辫，因为我决定留刘海，而留长它们花了好久。看看这个可怜的马尾辫。我的意思是，我不得不说，那看起来像帕姆在第一季到第三季的发型。我以前用半刘海做的那个小弧度，就是让我想起那个。哦，刘海。好吧，奥斯卡想让每个人都知道他不是塔可钟狗的配音。
Toby is not a virgin. The conference room is a buzz. Everyone is trading rumors about themselves. Jim is like, guys, has everybody heard a crazy rumor about themselves today? And Michael is like, you know what? Let's just forget all of them. Well, they start tracing it all back. And guess where every rumor came from?
托比不是处男。会议室里议论纷纷。每个人都在交换关于自己的谣言。吉姆说，伙计们，今天每个人都听到关于自己的疯狂谣言了吗？迈克尔说，你知道吗？让我们忘掉所有这些吧。好吧，他们开始追根溯源。猜猜每个谣言是从哪里来的？
Mm-hmm. Michael. Who runs to the elevator because he knows. But the entire gang stops him, confronts him. Dwight cannot believe that he told people that Shrewt Farms uses store-bought manure when Dwight showed Michael where his manure comes from. Oh, my gosh.
嗯哼。迈克尔。他跑向电梯，因为他知道。但整个团队拦住了他，与他对质。德怀特无法相信他告诉人们施鲁特农场使用商店买的肥料，而德怀特明明带迈克尔看过他的肥料是从哪里来的。哦，天哪。
Eventually, Michael is going to admit that he started the rumors. I actually love that Michael's like, hey, I'm a victim here too. I mean, people were saying I was a J-Crew model. Exactly. But Michael says he had to start all the rumors because one of the rumors is true.
最终，迈克尔承认是他散布了这些谣言。我其实很喜欢迈克尔说，嘿，我也是受害者。我的意思是，人们说我是J-Crew的模特。没错。但迈克尔说他不得不散布所有这些谣言，因为其中一个谣言是真的。
He's not going to say which one. He starts going around, and Jim and Pam, Realize pretty quickly what the real rumor is. Yeah. That Stanley's having an affair. But everyone's insisting that Michael say what the real rumor is, and he's about to reveal that.
他不会说具体是哪一个。他开始四处走动，吉姆和帕姆很快意识到真正的谣言是什么。是的。斯坦利有外遇。但每个人都坚持要迈克尔说出真正的谣言是什么，他正要揭露那个。
So Jim jumps in and says, the real thing is that Pam is pregnant. And right away, Angel's like, I knew it. I know. And then Kevin is like, I knew it because Pam's boobs were bigger. Booms, boobs, boobs. And Jim's like, okay, buddy, okay. We had a fan question from Renata P from Rio de Janeiro, Brazil.
所以吉姆插话说，真正的事情是帕姆怀孕了。安吉拉立刻说，我就知道。我知道。然后凯文说，我就知道，因为帕姆的胸部变大了。胸部，胸部，胸部。吉姆说，好了，伙计，好了。我们收到了来自巴西里约热内卢的雷娜塔·P的粉丝提问。
What are your thoughts about Jim's revelation to the whole office that the rumor about Pam being pregnant was actually true? I know he was trying to protect Stanley and it never really bothered me before. But in rewatching the scene yesterday, I was like, hey, maybe he should have had a conversation with Pam before telling everyone. What do we think? I actually think Pam and Jim were on the same page in this moment because the way Pam's body language was, and your dialogue. It's like the two of you both knew, oh, no. Oh, no. He's about to destroy Stanley's life. Oh, no, we've got to do something. I felt like I saw that internal dialogue between the two of you. Well, I'm glad to hear you say that, Angela, because that was our intention. The intention
对于吉姆向整个办公室透露帕姆怀孕的谣言其实是真的，你们有什么看法？我知道他是在试图保护斯坦利，以前这从来没有真正困扰过我。但在昨天重看这一幕时，我想，嘿，也许他在告诉大家之前应该先和帕姆商量一下。你们怎么看？我其实认为帕姆和吉姆在那一刻是达成共识的，因为帕姆的肢体语言，还有你们的对话。就像你们俩都知道，哦，不。哦，不。他要毁了斯坦利的生活。哦，不，我们得做点什么。我觉得我看到了你们俩之间的那种内心对话。好吧，很高兴听到你这么说，安吉拉，因为那确实是我们的意图。意图
was that Jim and Pam were going to both come to this realization. And this is like they share a brain thing. They're a couple. And so it's a couple brain. Couple brains. So, So I totally get where Renata is coming from. Our hope was that you would see Pam's permission in that moment. Her participation in the moment. And how we're sort of giving each other eye contact was our intention. Of course, Michael, though, is like, no, no, no, that's not it. And you guys are like, oh, will you stop it?
是吉姆和帕姆都要意识到这一点。这就像他们共享一个大脑。他们是一对。所以这是夫妻大脑。夫妻大脑。所以，我完全理解雷娜塔的感受。我们的希望是你们能在那一刻看到帕姆的许可。她在那一刻的参与。以及我们如何通过眼神交流，这就是我们的意图。当然，迈克尔却说，不，不，不，不是那样的。你们说，哦，你能停下来吗？
Like, just like, ugh. So she has to go out and get her sonogram photo. One of my favorite things is when you go get your sonogram photo is that Kelly says, we're just all going to wait here? That was just Mindy. That was just Mindy. Well, we had a fan question from Ella R in England. Is Pam's sonogram real? And if not, how was it created? Good question. Our graphic artist, Ryan Cosgrove, he made this for us. He repurposed an existing sonogram from his friend's wife. Oh. So somewhere out there, there's a little baby. A little baby who got some screen time. Yeah. Well, when Pam presents her.
就像，呃。所以她不得不出去拿她的超声波照片。我最喜欢的事情之一就是当你去拿超声波照片时，凯利说，我们都要在这里等吗？那是敏迪即兴发挥的。那是敏迪。好吧，我们收到了来自英国埃拉·R的粉丝提问。帕姆的超声波是真的吗？如果不是，它是怎么制作的？好问题。我们的平面设计师瑞安·科斯格罗夫为我们制作了这个。他重新利用了他朋友妻子的现有超声波。哦。所以在某个地方，有一个小宝宝。一个获得了一些出镜机会的小宝宝。是的。好吧，当帕姆展示她的
sonogram, Michael says, that's the inside of her vagina. Yeah, that's a picture of the inside of her vagina. Very quickly, Jim and Pam talking head where they're like, uh-huh, now it's clear. It's clear why we didn't want to tell these people. Well, now Jim and Pam are going to be like in the principal's office. Michael is devastated that they did not tell him first, that they did not tell him sooner. They only just told their parents. In the shooting draft, the line read like this. Did you piss on a stick? And I guess on the day they changed it to pee. But when I read that in the shooting draft, it was so jarring. I'm like, why would he say, did you piss on a stick?
超声波时，迈克尔说，那是她阴道的内部。是的，那是她阴道内部的照片。很快，吉姆和帕姆的独白镜头，他们说，嗯哼，现在清楚了。很清楚为什么我们不想告诉这些人。好吧，现在吉姆和帕姆要像在校长办公室一样了。迈克尔很崩溃，因为他们没有先告诉他，没有早点告诉他。在拍摄剧本中，台词是这样的。你尿在棍子上了吗？我想在拍摄当天他们把它改成了“尿”。但当我读到拍摄剧本里的那句时，太刺耳了。我想，他为什么要说，你尿在棍子上了吗？
Well, Michael has done something, guys. He has called Stanley's wife. This scene is so brilliant. When Aaron says Terry Hudson's on the line, you guys, your faces are like, you called her? And Michael's like, I got this. I can do it. I'll tell her I'm redecorating my condo, and they're like, no, Michael, don't. You guys are like, don't, don't.
好吧，迈克尔做了一件事，伙计们。他给斯坦利的妻子打了电话。这一幕太精彩了。当亚伦说特里·哈德森在线上时，你们的表情就像是，你给她打了电话？迈克尔说，我能搞定。我可以做到。我会告诉她我正在重新装修我的公寓，他们说，不，迈克尔，别。你们就像是，别，别。
But he has this whole thing. It's going to have to play out over months where he's redecorating the condo. They're going to get quotes, but then they're going to get an argument about the cost of things. And eventually he's just going to have to call it all off. And he literally is like, I've got this. And Pam is like, Michael, please don't. Michael picks up the phone and says, hey, what up, Cynthia? I mean, just amazing.
但他有这一整套计划。这必须在几个月内上演，他正在重新装修公寓。他们会得到报价，但随后他们会因为成本问题发生争执。最终他将不得不取消这一切。他真的说，我能搞定。帕姆说，迈克尔，求你了，别。迈克尔拿起电话说，嘿，怎么了，辛西娅？我的意思是，太棒了。
Jim starts to walk over and Michael is waving him off like, I got it, I got it. And then he goes, hold on a second, Cynthia. And then Jim just hangs up the phone. We had a fan question from Kelsey S from Chandler, Arizona, who says, this is my absolute favorite episode of all time. This is my comfort episode. I watch it all of the time. And I need to know if the scene where Michael answers the call from Terry was at all
吉姆开始走过去，迈克尔挥手让他走开，好像在说，我搞得定，我搞得定。然后他说，等一下，辛西娅。然后吉姆直接挂断了电话。我们收到了来自亚利桑那州钱德勒的凯尔西·S的粉丝提问，她说，这是我这辈子最喜欢的一集。这是我的治愈剧集。我一直都在看。我需要知道迈克尔接听特里电话的那一幕是否是
improvised or was it scripted, everything from Steve's reaction to his hand movements on the phone is hilarious and I love it. This entire scene played out exactly as scripted. Minus the piss. Minus the piss. That's the only thing that changed. It is 100% on the page. Guess what? Terry was already suspicious about this affair and this, I guess proves it. Stanley is going to vandalize Michael's car. Stanley takes a crowbar to Michael's car and destroys it. We had a couple of fan questions about this. One from Roheat R in Norman, Oklahoma.
即兴创作的还是照剧本演的，从史蒂夫的反应到他在电话上的手部动作，一切都很搞笑，我太喜欢了。整个场景完全按照剧本演的。减去尿。减去尿。那是唯一改变的东西。它100%在页面上。你猜怎么着？特里已经怀疑这次外遇了，我想这证明了这一点。斯坦利要破坏迈克尔的车。斯坦利拿着撬棍砸了迈克尔的车并毁了它。我们收到了几个关于这个的粉丝提问。一个来自俄克拉荷马州诺曼的罗希特·R。
How much did the scene of Stanley smashing Michael's car cost? And Monica F from North Carolina said, It's so funny to me that Stanley had enough time to put on his sunglasses before smashing Michael's car. Well, guys, Leslie did this smashing. Randy said he had a very good time. I would too. I would too.
斯坦利砸迈克尔车的场景花了多少钱？来自北卡罗来纳州的莫妮卡·F说，斯坦利在砸迈克尔的车之前有足够的时间戴上太阳镜，这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，伙计们，是莱斯利完成了这次砸车。兰迪说他玩得很开心。我也会的。我也会的。
He said that they had to establish him wearing the sunglasses earlier in the episode so that during this scene, he would have eye protection in case anything flew up in his eyes. Randy said he smashed the heck out of that car. It was a oneer, just one take. It cost over $4,000 to repay. I don't doubt it. When he caught up and started to mess with a convertible top?
他说他们必须在剧集早些时候安排他戴上太阳镜，这样在这一幕中，如果有什么东西飞进他的眼睛，他就有护眼装备。兰迪说他把那辆车砸得稀巴烂。这是一次性完成的，只拍了一次。维修费用超过4000美元。我不怀疑。当他追上来开始摆弄敞篷车顶时？
Yeah. I was like, oh, no. Mm-hmm. That's some chiching. Well, guys, that's basically the end of this episode. The interns have a little talking head at the end, where we find out that Michael just called them Jet Lee, Julia Stiles, and Alan Thick. And that Eric never really learned how many pieces of paper were in a ream of paper.
是的。我当时想，哦，不。嗯哼。那得花不少钱。好吧，伙计们，这基本上是这一集的结尾。实习生在最后有一个小独白，我们发现迈克尔刚才叫他们杰特·李、朱莉娅·斯泰尔斯和艾伦·锡克。而且埃里克从来没有真正学会一令纸里有多少张纸。
In the very end credits at 21 minutes 34. seconds. Randy Cordray pointed something out to us, and I want to share it to you. We see the name of our new unit production manager for season six, Steve Burgess. Steve was a very old and dear friend of Randy, and I loved Steve Burgess so much. He went on to be our line producer in the last seasons. We adore him, and it was so fun to finally see his name. Randy said when he brought him on board that Steve's contributions behind the scenes were immeasurable. Yes. And, And we are still in touch with Steve today.
在21分34秒的最后演职员表中。兰迪·科德雷向我们指出了某件事，我想和你们分享。我们看到了我们第六季新任制片经理的名字，史蒂夫·伯吉斯。史蒂夫是兰迪的一位非常老且亲爱的朋友，我非常喜欢史蒂夫·伯吉斯。他后来成为了我们最后几季的执行制片人。我们崇拜他，终于看到他的名字真是太有趣了。兰迪说，当他让他加入时，史蒂夫在幕后的贡献是不可估量的。是的。而且，我们今天仍然与史蒂夫保持联系。
So when we get to those episodes where he was the line producer, we're going to get to hear from him. Yay. Well, that's gossip. Do you think I'll end up in the gossip magazines because of my soup dreams with Brad Pitt? Would that be so weird? That would be such a full circle moment. I know. Who's going to write about it?
所以当我们看到他担任执行制片人的那些剧集时，我们将能听到他的声音。耶。好吧，这就是八卦。你认为我会因为我和布拉德·皮特的汤梦而出现在八卦杂志上吗？那会很奇怪吗？那将是一个非常圆满的时刻。我知道。谁会写这个？
I don't know. Maybe no one. No one cares about my soup. Your fake soup? My fake soup. With Brad Pitt. Listen, if we ever hear from Brad Pitt about the fake soup, I will be so excited. If we ever hear from...
我不知道。也许没人。没人关心我的汤。你那虚构的汤？我那虚构的汤。和布拉德·皮特一起。听着，如果我们有一天听到布拉德·皮特谈论那碗虚构的汤，我会非常兴奋。如果我们有一天听到……
What? What? Oh, my gosh. What if one day? What if one day? I'm sorry. I'm having a dream. And I'm so sorry for anyone listening.
什么？什么？哦，天哪。如果有一天呢？如果有一天呢？对不起。我在做梦。对于任何正在听的人，我感到非常抱歉。
I probably then scared you. What if one day we are doing office ladies and we get some soup delivered and it's from Brad Pitt. Come on. Could that happen? And you know what? Guess who's going to deliver it? Kianu. If Kianno Reeves delivered soup made by Bread Pit.
我可能刚才吓到你了。如果有一天我们正在做《办公室女孩》节目，我们收到了一些送来的汤，而且是布拉德·皮特送的，会怎么样？拜托。那会发生吗？你知道吗？猜猜谁会送来？基努。如果基努·里维斯送来了布拉德·皮特做的汤。
And then all of a sudden, Idriselba is going to, like, bring some music into it, and we're going to just have, like, a soup eating party? What has just happened? I don't know. Well, save it for nifty 50s. Musical review. And you guys, we hope you have a fantastic week. Once again, thank you to Randy Cord.
然后突然之间，伊德里斯·艾尔巴要带一些音乐进来，我们要举办一个喝汤派对？刚才发生了什么？我不知道。好吧，留到“俏皮50年代”音乐评论里再说吧。伙计们，我们希望你们有一个美妙的一周。再次感谢兰迪·科德雷、
Trey, Max Carver, and all of you guys for sending in your questions and your comments. We hope you have a great week. We love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
马克斯·卡弗，以及所有发送问题和评论的你们。我们希望你们有一个愉快的一周。我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女孩》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女孩》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratt. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女孩》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特创作的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。